advice asian men and broads
all right this is interesting i never
heard this this uh i don't think i've
ever had i'm already anticipating i've
not not had this question before bill
as an asian man oh my god i was at a
four-way
stop the other day and i [ __ ] up and
pulled out in front of this guy and this
asian dude's looking at me
like what the [ __ ] is your problem and i
wanted to be like huh you see
stereotypes aren't true
are they i was the idiot
all right as an asian man i feel like
the system
is rigged against me for romance
i'm a senior in college right now pretty
fit awesome grades no [ __ ]
somewhat a gym bro and i've had
experiences before on one in on first
and second base but can't seem to hit a
home run with the ladies
these broads in college just don't think
asian men are attractive
whether it's the small dick jokes being
i mean that didn't help you guys
being the most non-attractive male race
just ain't gonna cut it even if you have
confidence
and just approach dude cancel all of
that [ __ ]
canceled as a bald redheaded male dude
what you need is a
vibe i'm gonna send you a [ __ ] video
man
i'm gonna send you a [ __ ] video i'm
gonna have the great
john travolta is vinnie barbarino
set you [ __ ] straight this is one of
my favorite [ __ ] clips
it's hilarious and it's in in a way it's
absolutely true
go on instagram i'm gonna post it uh
this is he's teaching arnold horschack
he's teaching arnold schwarz uh horshack
about how to be
uh how to how to get with the lid dude
all you need is a vibe
okay you just need a [ __ ] vibe uh
he said i'm i'm about to commission into
the army soon as an officer and i'm
worried it'll be harder to find romance
what are your thoughts
and [ __ ] you uh this is my thoughts
hit the gym [ __ ] get your confidence
up
i'm feeling like you like the comic
who's walking on stage
already feeling like they're gonna bomb
and then they bomb
i feel like you're on your heels all
right
who gives a [ __ ] just be [ __ ] you
know do it
who gives a [ __ ] just get up there and
swing for the fences
you're gonna connect at some point and
you're gonna get laid and then you're
gonna get the monkey off your back
you're gonna be relaxed and you know
it's gonna it's gonna be raining
all right that's how you gotta think
about it all right you're gonna do
you're gonna do fine all right i mean
if i did all right out there you're
gonna do fine you're gonna do great
okay just [ __ ] i cannot stress that
enough
you gotta just have confidence and you
gotta have a sense of humor dude hitting
on chicks and getting
shut down okay getting the heisman
is [ __ ] hilarious
and once you find the whole the the
humor in it dude bombing is a comic
that's something that's humiliating is
it's [ __ ] funny
it's [ __ ] making mistakes [ __ ] up
is hilarious all right and if you can
laugh at yourself and not give a [ __ ]
all this people want to be around you
because everybody wants to because
everybody like
that's what people are going for in life
is when something bad happens
to not let it depress them so they can
enjoy life rather than walking around
you know moping around listening to
[ __ ] emo music and just giving in to
the fact
you know that you know things haven't
worked out to you at that point in life
[ __ ] all of that dude [ __ ] all of that
okay i mean jesus christ
you're in the prime of your goddamn life
all right
you're a little bit of a late bloomer i
was too it all works out
okay you hear me it's gonna work out and
i'm posting that vinnie barbarino
clip just for you all right bill how do
you tell a girl she sucks in bed
um hey bill how do you tell a girl she
sucks in bed without hurting her
feelings or making her
embarrassed is it okay to give pointers
in the bedroom or would you make or
would it make
that make me look like a dick help me
out bill
go [ __ ] yourself um all right the first
half
there's no way to tell a girl she sucks
in bed there's no way for a woman to
tell a guy
he sucks in bed without hurting the
feelings all right
let's be politically correct there's no
way for a guy to tell another guy
if they live in an alternative lifestyle
2013.
no one wants to hear that um
well this is what i would do
you can't just make somebody good in bed
the potential has to be there there has
to be a certain god-given talent
you know what i mean i mean some women
they
they reach for your package like they're
grabbing something out of the cupboard
you know what i mean there's just no
it's you know what's funny about women
being bad in bed is there's not a lot
of um there's not a lot of story
i think guys not knowing what they're
doing is is
pretty well documented and guilty as
charged
guilty is charged you know but um
it's it's definitely a two-way street
what i would do is
if you feel she has potential uh rather
than give her pointers
like hey listen you're doing a great job
in there it's a couple things like make
some halftime adjustments maybe you
could do that like stop halfway through
[ __ ]
you know have her run into the bathroom
and as you run in somebody interviews
you
yeah well you know the first half hour
was pretty good there's definitely some
things we could do better uh you know my
balls are kind of lonely
and uh you know she's gotta you know she
doesn't have a good rhythm we're gonna
try to work on our rhythm
in the uh second half all right yeah go
[ __ ] yourself you know runs back in
um i would suggest rather than okay
definitely don't tell if she sucks do
not give pointers
i would the key word here is guiding
guiding and informative moaning
[Laughter]
i would say would be
the uh the most user-friendly
way to protect this girl's feelings it
is
that's what you have to do um i need
more information do you feel she's aware
how does she suck in bed like i said is
she grabbing your dick like she's you
know
reaching into a mailbox to see what the
[ __ ] in there or
is she just shy you got to help me out
here i
don't i don't know um
you know that that's what i would do
i would i would guide her and if i guide
her i don't mean
pushing her head down it guiding
no forcing none of that type of
stuff and uh
and then where you got to be simon
cowell is um don't give her any
um sympathetic moans
when she starts picking up that the
moans you know
you know don't give her any sympathy
once if it ain't doing it for you don't
give her a
yeah don't do that just dead silence
okay she has to know it's she it's it's
not working
i don't want to tell you dude i know i
told this story before i hooked up with
this girl one time and we were having
sex doggy style
and you know when i come forward you're
supposed to back in
you know like we're clapping
uh with crutches
is that a uh was that a [ __ ] was that
one of those dances with wolves names
clapping with crotches sorry hacky joke
um
yeah i know what she was doing when i
went back she went back when i went
forward she went forward so i was in her
but there was no friction
so i was starting to have a performance
problem before i ever so gently put one
hand on her hip and the other on the
back of her neck and just sort of
stopped her
went back and then pulled her but it
still didn't work it was like not only
does she not know how to do it she was i
think almost as tall as i was
you know so doggy style you know they
got to have kind of like you know
you can get a little too high there you
know without getting too graphic so i
was already dealing with that
you know um
i don't know beautiful girl though a
little bit of advice here
listen to this [ __ ] situation this
guy got himself into
all right bill my girlfriend is 10 years
older than me oh jesus
she has two kids oh jesus and has been
married
and divorced twice
dude what the [ __ ] i'm 26
jesus christ college graduate
has any of this made any sense to any of
you would anybody else be out there
26 college [ __ ] graduate have a
girlfriend 10 years older than you with
two kids who's been married and divorced
twice
good god man he goes i consider myself
somewhat intelligent
i'm sure you are but not in this area um
by that i mean you should have no
problem understanding this email well
yeah i know everybody trashes me i know
i know i'm the worst when it comes to
reading this [ __ ]
so anyways here we go he says four weeks
ago
i found text messages to some dude on my
girlfriend's phone
that although innocent enough made it
clear
that whoever she was texting was on more
familiar grounds
than just some work colleague or a
friend
jesus christ dude is there going to be a
happy ending here
i confronted her about it and
it predictably led to a lot of finger
pointing we went back and forth and
for a few days and aired out our
grievances
but it seemed agreeable now he makes i
guess point number two
to oh two more weeks passed by and lo
and behold
i find more text messages from the same
[ __ ] guy at first i tell myself okay
maybe she can't break things off with
this dude so quickly
jesus christ dude you know sometimes
liberal thought is a is a great thing
like let's have a fair [ __ ] trial for
somebody
before we hang them from the nearest
tree but then there's times it's [ __ ]
stupid this
is just liberal thought to the i mean
how much of a benefit of the doubt can
you give somebody
you know so you go so i confront her
about it and this leads to another round
of finger pointing
at which point she tells me to pack my
[ __ ] and leave
well dude i'm gonna tell you right now
before i read the rest of it that's
[ __ ] great
you didn't have to do any dirty work
you're out you're [ __ ] out
so anyways he goes we're separated for a
week when she asked me to come back and
move in
dude this chick is a [ __ ] psycho here
we go
we talk about our future together how
sorry she is
to have done that to me etc etc for
[ __ ] sakes we even talking about
getting married when things finally
[ __ ] evened out
i was full of piss and vinegar and felt
vindicated vindicated
that i was the one wronged in the whole
situation and
she was actually making good by taking
responsibility for what she had done
through taking responsibility would have
been [ __ ] after
dude the second you see those weird
texts just get i'm telling you right now
just get out of the relationship
there isn't oh sorry sorry about the
no that that's it it's over it's [ __ ]
over
um but whatever you're 26
i guess you still haven't learned i was
dumb in my 20s so
here we go let's read the rest of this
um all was well and good
until she didn't come home this thursday
night november 11th
she came in friday morning with no
explanation no apology no nothing
she asked me to give her some more time
but i decided to cut bait
and just get the [ __ ] out of the
situation hang on a second everybody
sorry i had to give him a little
applause break there of course
now i'm wracked with guilt of leaving
the woman i loved and lived with for the
past
five [ __ ] years you got with her when
you were 21 dude
she was 31. wait let's do the math she
was 31 you were 21 she was already
married twice
all right this chick's a psycho and you
know what that means she's [ __ ] great
in bed
you were 21 she [ __ ] devastated you
with [ __ ] her [ __ ] right
best blow job you ever had isn't that
what happened and next thing you know
you were too [ __ ]
too young and dumb you fell for a
ah jesus christ you stayed there for
five [ __ ] years
so anyway i guess this chick still
calling him telling she still wants to
get back together
i feel like every time i sack up and do
what i think is best for me she wants me
back
and every time what i do what's best for
us as a couple
she uses that as an opportunity to [ __ ]
with me all over again yes
yes you're absolutely right
listen to your gut this guy see
he knows the [ __ ] answers he's he's
listening to his gut good [ __ ] man
um is this is it just that chicks can't
handle a guy that is emotionally
invested
or do i just happen to be dealing with
one of those sociopaths
that doesn't give a [ __ ] what she does
so long as it suits her in the moment
yes there's plenty of [ __ ] good women
well that's not plenty good women
there's good women out there all right
just like good good man's hard to find
this finding a good woman is also
difficult
all right but no you happen to be
dealing with an absolute [ __ ]
sociopath
all right she had a [ __ ] up childhood
something happened to her she either got
touched her [ __ ] dad took off
i don't or she just got the [ __ ] she
got one of those bad brains
you know i can tell you guys my theory
on that the a brain the b
brain and the c brain the a brain is the
genius the b
brain is the uh dude he's a good [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know
fitzy and then the sea brain
is you're a [ __ ] mouth-breathing
[ __ ] all right
and when it comes to being a sociopath
that's like just uh
that's just like getting an option on
the car all brains come with that option
it's all available like satellite radio
you know you get satellite radio and a
[ __ ] bentley
you can also get it my [ __ ] prius all
right
so did that make any [ __ ] sense you
got a sociopath with the [ __ ]
she could even have the a brain that's
the sad thing about having a [ __ ] up
childhood she could actually be a
[ __ ] genius but she's got that
sociopath [ __ ] so tell her to go call
[ __ ] dr drew all right
and you get the [ __ ] out of the
relationship so anyways he say
i'd imagine you'd agree that i did the
right thing
uh but it always helps to get a little
bit of better perspective on it dude i
totally understand
you've been in a five-year relationship
you're emotionally invested in this [ __ ]
so you know what the right thing to do
is but your emotions keep [ __ ] with
you
all right so what you got to know is
just
look going through a breakup is painful
all right it's not going to not be
painful but just because it's painful
doesn't mean that it's not the right
thing to do you are 100
[ __ ] percent doing the right [ __ ]
thing you're 26 year old years old
you're in the prime of your [ __ ] life
all right
get out of that situation okay she's 10
years older than you
by the time you're 29 she's going to be
hitting [ __ ] menopause
all right or something like that
whatever sliding into it i have no
[ __ ] idea what she's going to be
doing
she's going to be wearing those mom
jeans at that point
if she's not already which i don't think
she is
she's probably that [ __ ] you know
that uh
that anorexic cougar look you know
where they got a varicose vein in
between their [ __ ] you can see their
breastplate
uh jesus christ bill stay on topic yeah
so dude just get out of that
hang out with your [ __ ] fellas you
know hang on your buddies go out and
[ __ ]
have some beers join a gym get [ __ ]
shredded
and go out start talking [ __ ] when
you're ready but
don't go back to that man you dodged a
[ __ ] bullet
the fact that you were with her for five
years and you didn't knock her up
and you got out of it and even after
five years you're only 26 years old you
made the best [ __ ] move you're gonna
make
all right and now this is what you need
to do you've been in a relationship for
five years
you need to be single for at least a
[ __ ] year and a half
and i don't mean just be single and
[ __ ] booze
figure out what the [ __ ] you're looking
for all right and when you meet a girl
if she doesn't have it just walk banger
and leave
you know there's nothing wrong with
having a good [ __ ] time but do not
get sucked into another [ __ ]
relationship
because you're gonna because you're
gonna have to go through this [ __ ] again
you know we're just sitting there and
you know it's [ __ ] wrong but you
don't want to go through the [ __ ]
pain of it you keep coming back it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare good for you
sir i'm [ __ ] proud of you you did the
right thing
you're sort of [ __ ] wavering because
you're going through the emotions you're
only 26 you got with her when you were
21 it's probably your first major
[ __ ] breakup
so it's acceptable that you [ __ ] up
and went back that second time but do
not go
back again and if any of your [ __ ]
friends are listening to this don't let
him do that [ __ ]
all right tie him to a [ __ ] bar stool
and start throwing drinks down his
throat
um anyway advice
uh by the way can more people like that
please write in
um advice hey bill love your podcast bro
uh been a fan for years through your
stand-ups and movies etc
i have an issue bill i myself
am black and i'm dating a white woman oh
jesus why would you do that
who has an interracial child
uh parenthesis not a problem okay
the problem is the way her kid behaves
i was just [ __ ] with the white chick
thing by the way okay the problem is
the way her kid behaves i was brought up
in the whoop your kids era
uh that we as a society have forgotten
yeah i don't think you want to do that
you don't do that the kid is for and
seems to get away with murder
talking back acting out the whole nine
you know i really like this woman but
she seems to get upset when i mention
anything about her kid's behavior
like it's normal or some [ __ ] i wasn't
brought up that way
so his behavior bothers me just thinking
about his behavior is bothering me too
so should i stick it out and just deal
with it or should i say
[ __ ] that and move on uh thanks for
listening and stay funny
hope i hear this on your podcast your
ginger bastard
um i say you say [ __ ] it and move on
because if i think you really had
feelings for this woman
that would have come up and you would
have said you know i really like this
person i'm really
i love her i'm really into her i i this
is just something that i'm just worried
is going to be
you didn't say any of that you're just
like yeah i'm dating this white broad
she's got an interracial kid not a
problem
okay but as far as if you do decide to
stick around
okay you don't need to hit kids you
should never hit kids that's not a good
way to do it
you just have to remember the kid's four
and can't reach the food
so you have all the power all right i'm
not saying starving either i'm just
using that as an example that you are
totally controlling the environment
but if you're dealing with this woman
who you you know
sounds like you're having a good time
banging her but i don't
see like you're into her um if it if it
moves on to another level then
uh at the very least the kid has to
respect you
and you can do that without raising your
voice you can do that without inflicting
pain you can do it without starving them
but you just you just don't tolerate it
like you know when they start whining
and crying
you just you don't even address it let
them have that little hissy fit
flip out and then whatever they hissy
fitting and flipping out about you still
don't give them
and then just say to them like why would
i give you whatever they tell you i want
an ice cream why would i give you ice
cream after you just behave like that
because i wanna yes yeah
yeah you're not you're never gonna get
ice cream when you behave like that and
that's how it is now you can go
deal with that now and go flip out and
throw yourself on the couch i don't give
a [ __ ]
okay you're not strong enough to open
the fridge so you're not getting it
until you behave the way you need to be
behaving
um so that's what i do if you stick
around but i mean just the way you wrote
about her
i would i would move on uh
all right masturbating or cheating hey
bill burrington
uh burnington raincoat factory
um burlington coat factory i got it
oh burlington you did have the l in
there i couldn't see it hey
billy burlington coat factory raincoat
factory
uh for your love of raincoats over
umbrellas
oh i love a raincoat um i live in
florida
and to me a man who uses either
is a little limp-wristed oh yeah you got
those steel
balls hanging off the back of your truck
um
but that is an old-school guy think that
if you actually dress for the weather
that makes you a [ __ ] you always have
to act like it's a nice spring day
uh but moving on to ask your advice i've
been waiting
with i've been with my fiance for eight
years now
and even before dating i had become
bored with regular
regularly watching porn online
masturbation
so one day 10 years ago i discovered
online dating sites oh boy
and started to talk to women i met
online on the phone
sorry and it would eventually
what the hell is it led to phone sex
ever since then masturbating by myself
is uninteresting and unfulfilling
i've continued this practice since being
exclusive with my current fiance and was
wondering
if it's considered cheating uh that's
always an easy question if you told her
you were doing this
how would she react i never used my real
name
and haven't updated my pics since
initially signing up 10 years ago
and never met any of the women offline i
use them for phone sex
as long as possible and then when they
want to move things further along i
stopped speaking to them
i've never cheated on any previous
girlfriends in my life and was wondering
your thoughts on this thanks in advance
p.s i love the podcast and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah talk to a therapist
talk to a therapist one of the problems
that is developed
in this age of technology is yeah you're
addicted to phone sex
and yeah in you know i had like a porn
addiction
that i just i finally realized hey i'm
[ __ ] doing this all the time
this is how you know you're addicted to
porn if you try to jerk off
with just your thoughts and if you can't
make it happen you got a [ __ ] problem
that needs to be addressed
so i would talk to a professional and
just say you have
a problem and i would nip this
in the in the bud is that how you say it
i always forget butt or bud nip it in
the bud and just [ __ ]
uh um
handle this [ __ ] before you get married
because living a life like that is gonna
wear on you and you're gonna feel like a
piece of [ __ ]
so um i wouldn't do that i mean how
would you like it if she was doing that
would you consider that not cheating you
know
of course you would what you're doing is
wrong um
so i i would talk to i would go to a
therapist and talk to him and they will
[ __ ]
help it out and you don't need to be
embarrassed they have heard every
[ __ ] thing
in the world and what you have here is
like
is like a misdemeanor compared to what
the [ __ ] they hear every goddamn day and
they'll help you through it
and you'll you'll be back to being a
really
sort of a normal person because this
whole [ __ ] thing jerking off using
technology
is is if you really think about it is
goes against the laws of nature because
it did not exist
for 99 of the time that human beings
have been on earth
and i feel like we are all the lab rats
of it right now
and i feel like
in the future people are going to be way
more careful about what they watch
way more careful about everything and
way more like monitoring it we're back
in the day you know you had a bottle of
scotch in the bottom
[ __ ] desk drawer you know mayor i was
married tyler moore she come in oh mr
grant should be all upset and he'd
[ __ ] pour her a drink
he did that today that'd be the end of
your [ __ ] career so
um you know this [ __ ] is just
sort of like you know when cocaine first
came out doctors said it was no more
addicting than caffeine
and then a bunch of people ruin their
lives over it so don't ruin your life
over this you got a great
person that you want to marry you owe it
to them and yourself go to a therapist
work it out i think you'll be fine um
all right advice on divorced parents
uh dear billy nia's
box breaker oh jesus uh love your comedy
and hope things are well with nia and
the kids
i have a problem i could use some advice
with my father divorced my mother after
18 years of marriage
i was 9 years old i'm 23 now my father
told us
he left her for the way she approached
parenting
so she'd yell when trying to get us
to do something and other examples i
won't get into my mother believes my
father
cheated on her and left this might be
true since he entered a relationship
immediately after filing for divorce you
know it's usually a red flag
but i honestly don't know since then
i've been
i've been great i've built great
relationships with both
and love them very much here's my
problem during the divorce my father
claims my mother took a substantial
amount
of ammunition and ammunition loading
components
he manufactures his own ammos out of
spent casings
which are valued very light very highly
especially now during the pandemic my
father always mentioned wanting to get
it all back
i'd like to see it return since both my
father and i are avid shooters and it's
something we've bonded over
while i never seen this stuff at my
mother's place
after she sold the original house i
wouldn't put a pastor to have taken it
i just don't know how to bring it up to
my mother without starting any problems
or causing any drama
during the divorce things got very
heated with both parents filing
divorce orders restraining orders on
each other
at one point first my dad wasn't allowed
to see my sister and i for three months
and my mother wasn't allowed to see us
for a month any advice you can give me
on how to approach this would be greatly
appreciated all right dude i would stay
out of it
i'd stay out of it i mean if that's how
the divorce went down and you're talking
ammunition and guns i would [ __ ] stay
out of that that is an easy one um just
stay out of it
just listen to your dad yep that sucks
maybe someday you know she'll come
around but do not
insert yourself in you know it's not
your
fault that they got divorced it's not
your fault that they handled the divorce
the way they did
it's not your fault your mother did or
didn't take the [ __ ] you're not a gum
shoe
it's not your it's not your job dude
just don't be taking on
other people's [ __ ] problems even if
they're your parents let them work that
[ __ ] out
and considering they're very volatile
people there's whole [ __ ] things with
guns and ammos and [ __ ] i would just
leave it alone that's what i would do
all right rhythms of comedy
what's up what's up pinky
i like that because that works in an
obvious way
and then also you know i'm a liberal
lefty so you might think i'm a commie i
like all of that what's up pinky that's
hilarious
uh this clip of uh mark norman's stand
up
to a drummer is bananas yeah i love when
people able to do that i also love mark
norman he's amazing i just want
you to know i just want to know what you
think of it i'm recently i'm a recent
fan
of the show and laugh hard every episode
go [ __ ] yourself
i guess that's what cool kids say um
i'll tell you something else there's a
comedian out there
uh greg hahn who's [ __ ] unbelievable
and then i watched him on the bob and
tom show playing drums he's a [ __ ]
beast uh there's a lot of drama uh
comedians that play drums greg hahn
is [ __ ] right up there man he was
crushing it
um all right that is it that is the
podcast i'll let you know on thursday
how my second shot of onsen
goes i'll talk to you see ya the guy
writes good morning sunshine
i like that when people started off nice
you know every once in a while get a
nice good morning sunshine and set it
instead of hey read this you [ __ ]
um anyways uh let's let's let's read
this shall we
are you ready okay gather round everyone
um i guess i'll just cut to the chase
here
very nice i appreciate that um i've been
with my girlfriend for about two and a
half years now
oh geez um the last two years
uh two of those years we've been living
together sharing bills
rent etc geez this sounds like a nice
situation
what could go wrong the whole serious
relationship
of the whole series relationship thing
um we've had our ups and downs but for
the most part the arrangement is working
out for the better
i have a roommate i can [ __ ] without
things getting awkward
we both make the same amount of money
and we enjoy
many of the same things so
here's the problem she's going to start
nursing school in about six months
this means she can no longer work at all
leaving me to pay for everything i
wouldn't mind doing this if i could
afford to but i can't
so she has decided that she wants to
move in with her parents again
for the two years she's in school she's
invited me to
move in with her and her parents
just pausing here so every guy listen to
this could be like oh my god
don't do it
uh moving with her and her parents so
that i too
could save some money i don't want to
move in with their parents though yeah
jesus there's a shocker
um don't get me wrong uh they're great
people and all but come on i'm a 28 year
old man and i can't imagine living under
somebody else's roof
no matter how cool they are when i was
kicked out of my parents house at 18
i had to couch surf with friends
families until i was able to support
myself
from that point on i've enjoyed the
independence of having a place of my own
to call my home
even if i had roommates it was partly my
place
and i could feel comfortable doing as i
pleased in a house of my peers
my girlfriend thinks i'm being
unreasonable she says it's an ego thing
maybe it is is that so wrong though am i
the only one in the world that doesn't
want to live with
with uh with his girlfriend's parents
because of this
of this situation her and i have have
been discussing
um how moving out of the same house
would affect our relationship
and if we should continue dating ah
god all right there's a lot of layers to
this
okay first and foremost you refer to
your girl girlfriend as a roommate you
can [ __ ]
so i'm this doesn't sound like the girl
you want to spend the rest of your life
with
but just in case you just wrote that
[ __ ] because you were trying to be funny
you know make me laugh or something on
the podcast listeners let's just take
this
let's just take this at [ __ ] face
value and say this is the girl that you
want to spend your life with
um dude don't move in with their parents
it's not what you want to do
you're not going to be happy and
you know you have every right to say i
don't want to i don't want to move in
with you
in your parents house you know and i'm
going to tell you right now she is going
to do
everything that she can to try to mind
[ __ ] you
into thinking that you're being a
selfish piece of [ __ ]
when actually she is being the selfish
one that is absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous that she thinks you
as a 28 year old
[ __ ] man not married to her
you know who can financially support
himself is then going to [ __ ] go move
in with her goddamn parents
tommy would you like some eggs you're
going to go back to that
what did i tell you about leaving
leaving your [ __ ]
sneakers near the davenport
dude [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] all of that
stand your ground okay
now this is what like women have like i
think like five or six different ways
that they can
try to convince you and it's all done
with the motion
okay they have this sweet way of doing
it they could be like no you know it
could be
could be nice you know get to know my
parents better
you like my parents right blah blah blah
blah
all that type of stuff or then they can
go the child-like way
well you gotta be nice if you moved in
with me right
they can use sex come on it could be fun
they got that big bed downstairs right
or they can go to anger actually they go
to us crying
that's another one i don't understand it
if you love me why would you move in
with me
and then finally anger
okay now anger always comes [ __ ] last
as far as i know they might go back to
tears but you have to understand that
when you get to
anger and they start pushing your
buttons
where they say [ __ ] like they start
challenging your manhood it's an ego
thing
uh yada yada whatever the [ __ ] they want
to say that this is where every guy
loses an argument with a woman you have
to understand
that when a woman gets mad and starts
just pushing your buttons
they say [ __ ] like they start
challenging your manhood it's an ego
thing
uh yada yada whatever the [ __ ] they want
to say that this is where every
guy loses an argument with a woman you
have to understand
that when a woman gets mad and starts
just pushing your buttons
okay that is the female version of the
hail mary
all right now i know i know you guys all
watch [ __ ] nfl
what does tom jackson say when they
throw the [ __ ] hail mary what do you
do
knock it down that's what you do and you
knock it down
by just being calm now if she just says
a bunch of [ __ ] and [ __ ] anger
okay and you actually respond to the
[ __ ] and insult her back
that's like taking an unnecessary
roughness call after you just stop the
other team
fourth and [ __ ] goal to end the game
now it's a penalty they got a first down
you gave them
all a whole [ __ ] four set of downs to
try to get in the [ __ ] end zone
you [ __ ] up you had the game one cause
you lost your cool don't ever lose your
cool
so this is what you do just let her say
all the [ __ ] she's gonna say
let her go through the [ __ ] 58
[ __ ] emotions and all the techniques
she's gonna try
the superman punch [ __ ] arm bar rear
naked choke all the [ __ ] she's gonna try
and you just stick to your [ __ ] guns
just say i understand
why you want to do it i i respect what
you you you
what you're saying here i should i don't
want to do it i'm not going to be happy
i don't want to move in with your
parents i'm not saying i don't love you
i'm not saying i'm not going to support
you but i i don't want to move in with
your parents it's not going to make me
happy
and you just keep you stick with that
all right
like a [ __ ] talking head for a
corporation
that just polluted the ocean it's an
unfortunate situation
we are uh exhausting all resources to
see how we can rectify the situation
and uh we have no further comment uh at
this time
you just have to stick with that and
then when in the very [ __ ]
end when she starts [ __ ] challenging
your manhood
um you [ __ ] whatever it's whatever
[ __ ]
childhood [ __ ] you told her or whatever
weakness you have and she starts trying
to bring that out you feel that fire
burning in your belly you just put it
out with calmness you just stay calm
okay and if you feel like you're gonna
lose your cool this is what you just say
you just say listen
you're being really hostile right now um
i think maybe we should discuss this
later on today or possibly tomorrow
when you're in a calmer mood
and then that's it dude that's it that's
the end of the [ __ ] game you just
knocked it down to the ground
and she would get [ __ ] mad and she
could flip out all the [ __ ] she want
she might even start knocking your [ __ ]
off the dresser she's just
looking for a reaction she's lost the
argument
she's lost the argument and you just
don't take
the [ __ ] bait and you know what the
sad thing is is i know this [ __ ]
and i still take the [ __ ] bait
a good ah sixty percent of the time
you know why because they're that
[ __ ] good
i'm drinking another smoothie by the way
and you know why they're that [ __ ]
good
because they don't have the option to
just kick the [ __ ] out of you
you know see we only go like three
levels in we have like a couple
approaches we can do
and then we always go well then i'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you right but
then you get to a female
that option's gone so now you're showing
up right
it's like you're playing tennis all you
got is a forehand all she's got to do is
hit it to your backhand you're [ __ ]
and it's over so i'm telling you you
guys
out there you gotta add to your argument
arsenal
okay practice it just get you just you
know what you got to do you got to
visualize it
all right because you're going to [ __ ]
up if you just try to do it in an
argument just lay there and just think
of all the mean
[ __ ] that she could possibly [ __ ] say
to you and just practice being calm
and the joy that you're gonna take when
you say you're being really hostile
right now
i think it'd be better if we discussed
it a little bit later possibly tomorrow
when you're in a calmer mood and just
seeing that pause
and that look on her face as her eyes
narrow like this [ __ ]
figured me out it's one of the great
moments
you know it's like that dude in jurassic
park when you actually had respect
for those whatever those [ __ ] those
raptors were
one douche to another douche recognizes
douche game
right there all right so there you go
that's how you handle it no
you know and this right now and she of
course she's gonna say i don't know if
we should continue dating
she's trying you know maybe this is a
[ __ ] ego thing she's trying all of
this [ __ ]
and she actually is already half mind
[ __ ] you
because you said she says it's an ego
thing and then you said maybe it is
you know is that so wrong though am i
wrong for feeling the things that i
actually
feel that's how [ __ ] much she's in
your [ __ ] head
like those little maggots that they
stuck in those [ __ ] helmets of those
guys in star trek
remember that it [ __ ] climbed in
their ears they were never the same
okay that's what a woman does
[Music]
it's what they do man i'm [ __ ] sorry
but that's what they do
pimp does the same [ __ ] thing all
right but you know
i don't i don't [ __ ] know i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm saying all right
you can't you can't have that you just
gotta [ __ ]
remain calm and never get involved in
the insulting thing now this isn't
straight across the board listen dude
if you just completely [ __ ] up like
you forgot her birthday and she's
flipping out
and [ __ ] calling you an insensitive
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that you need to apologize don't don't
you know if you forget her birthday
and like step on a birthday cake and
she's screaming at you don't be sitting
there with frosting on your foot going
okay you're being really hostile right
now i think it'd be better to discuss
this later when you're a little bit
calmer possibly tomorrow
because you're going to have every
kitchen knife is going to be coming at
you
and it will be a justifiable homicide
you know um married women
hey bill i know what i'm doing is wrong
oh geez
i'm a single guy who became friends with
the married woman at work here we go
devious maids we have a ton of stupid
[ __ ] in common
we even like the same flavor chips i
know it's [ __ ]
uh we became facebook friends how did
you become
facebook friends but just be honest with
me you're sorry you wanted to [ __ ] her
and you knew she was married you didn't
give a [ __ ]
all right i've been there
um here we go we uh we had like the same
flavored chips
we became facebook friends and little by
little
her messages started getting sexual yeah
and i'm sure you didn't facilitate that
on any you you you weren't stoking those
[ __ ] flames oh
whatever the expression goes you weren't
[ __ ] blowing on the hot coals at all
right you were just sitting there
talking about earth wind and fire and
all of a sudden she's like speaking of
fire
my [ __ ] is raging right now for your
[ __ ] to be in it you were like whoa hey
where did that come from i
i was just talking old r b music
um it's at the point where she comes
right out and told me she wants to [ __ ]
me
she's smoking hot with no kids and it's
so [ __ ] hard not to do something it
goes against all my beliefs but i can't
stop thinking about it i have a feeling
she wants out of her marriage but i
don't want to be a homewrecker
i've also have to see her at work so
it's extra hard
to tell her just tell her to [ __ ] off
i listen to you every monday and you
usually tell guys to whack it and see if
the feeling goes away well i already did
that
and it didn't work i'm just an average
attractive guy
and want to [ __ ] her but like i said i
know it's wrong
can you just come to canada and shoot me
in the [ __ ] head
that's hilarious oh and he said from
scotland
oh so she's loving that accent
um all right dude not only gonna be the
[ __ ] a married woman it's where you
work
and the odds of that coming and once you
start [ __ ] somebody at work as much
as you try and keep it on the down low
everybody knows
they can tell by your body language
everybody at work already knows that you
guys want to [ __ ] each other
they already know that so when you do
[ __ ] everybody's gonna know that
and then in six months when you go to
get a raise and you walk in there and
it's either going to be a
you're sitting across the desk from some
other guy that wanted to [ __ ] her but
didn't and is jealous of you
or b it's a woman who's jealous of that
hot [ __ ] that you [ __ ] and wants to
be as skinny as her
and is actually annoyed on some
subconscious level that you didn't try
to [ __ ] her
even though she wouldn't have [ __ ] you
either way it's gonna affect your money
uh don't do it don't do it
been there done that trust me don't
[ __ ] do it it does not end well
all right you don't want that on your
resume it's awful
it's awful it's an unforgivable act
um don't do it all right you don't want
to do it your dick wants
to do it and this is a great opportunity
to be the [ __ ] to
steal from the seinfeld show to be
master of your domain
all right you don't have to tell her to
[ __ ] off just say listen
all right i would love to have sex with
you too but i can't do it while you're
still married so when that situation
changes
come by and knock on the non-existent
door of my cubicle
and i will put you right on my [ __ ]
generic plastic desk that everybody else
has
that was [ __ ] bulk ordered from some
staple somewhere and i'll [ __ ] you in
front of everybody
and i'll have my [ __ ] oh face right
over the top of the cubicle
and i'll [ __ ] you right here at work but
until then
get out of my crib what movie was that
get out of my crib
[Music]
um all right plowing ahead uh bill uh so
something kind of ridiculous happened to
me the other day
and you're the only person who i think
might appreciate my point of view on the
matter okay
so there's this really good looking lady
uh that works at the sandwich shop
around the corner for my job
so i've been going there for like a year
now and i've always wanted to say
something to her but never did because
either the place was too busy at the
time or i just pussied out
usually the latter so the other day i
finally man up and decide to say
something and it went
a little something like this i go in
after two so it's not as busy i place my
order
she makes me a rap she hands me a rap
and i say
excuse me i've been coming in here for a
while and i've always wanted to
introduce myself
and before i can even get the words out
her smiling expression turns
blank her lips seal tight and she kind
of looks up at her eyebrows with that
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
look all over her face i can only equate
ah [ __ ] i just hit the wrong button on
my computer um
he goes i can only equate the look to an
uh to an employee
what an employee might have when they're
done with their work for the week and on
friday evening right as they feel like
they're going to get out of there the
boss comes
and drops another hour's worth of
paperwork on their desk they can't say
anything but you know they're thinking
you
[ __ ] prick so what i end up saying
after i get this look from this chick
is this is basically what the guy says
he said excuse me i've been coming in
here for a while and i've always wanted
to introduce myself you know what
[ __ ] it never mind
and he goes i turned around i just
walked out
all right and he goes now here's my
issue dude we've all been there all
right
we've all [ __ ] been there um all
right
so he goes now here's my issue it's not
that i was rejected big deal that [ __ ]
happens all the time right uh that's
like an ongoing theme in an adult life
and i've learned to live with it
jesus dude don't jump off a cliff here
um he goes my problem is that's a
society i can't even talk to society my
problem is society dictates that the guy
should approach the girl
and all the girl really needs to do is
look pretty throw a few signals and wait
for dudes to start clamoring like morons
is it fair no but then again it's really
not a big deal it's one of the
situations you grow accustomed to
but if that is the case and if all women
have to do
is be pretty then say yes or go
[ __ ] yourself could they at least wait
30 seconds for me to say whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm thinking
before they shoot me down
all she has to do is wait a minute and
say no thank you but instead
i get cut off by stink-eye mid-sentence
should i have told her to go [ __ ]
herself
what are your thoughts on this sort of
[ __ ] your true and loyal fan
bobo the douchebag all right um
what are my feelings on this all right
first of all dude we've all been there
we've all you know you got in your head
you're gonna come up there like [ __ ]
sean connery and one of those early
james bonds you even feel like you got a
[ __ ] tuxedo on
and then the second you open your mouth
you sound like [ __ ] arnold horshack
and you even want to shoot yourself down
at that point okay
um but and answer your question uh
should i have told her to go [ __ ]
herself
no that's not oh i mean
i'm i'm just you know having not been
there i
i can't it'd be it would depend on what
the look on her face was
or how she looked you know if uh if she
was just some hot girl
who didn't have a brain in her head yeah
then you tell her to go [ __ ] herself but
this is a really cute girl and you
actually feel like wow
i you know i'd like to get to know that
girl no you don't tell her to go [ __ ]
herself it's actually in that moment
when she gives you the stink eye
is when you have to come up with
something funny to say
something something clever something so
you show that you're not going to quit
in life
because that's what i hate to say dude
but that's what you showed her you
showed her that you have
you have the quit dna in your [ __ ]
ball bag and she's not going to want to
mate with you
[Laughter]
but fortunately there's plenty other
gazelles out there on the [ __ ]
serengeti that you can try to run down
you see the discovery channel
cheetah doesn't always [ __ ] run the
thing down sometimes it gets kicked in
the face
then it sits there feeling stupid
especially when it realizes it's being
filmed it's going to be on basic cable
there's where you can you can actually
look at a bright side it wasn't filmed
did you you just got to kind of come up
with something um in that moment that's
funny and i actually
kind of thought about it what i would
have said and i would have choked
even if i tried to come up with
something funny because in the moment
i would have felt like a douche and i
probably would have attacked what she
did for a living which is the worst
thing you can do
be like really you know you [ __ ]
you've been working here for a year and
a half two years i mean you're making
sandwiches
you're not getting any younger there
sweetie
all right you know i would it would have
been bad it would have been bad it's
very easy for me you know
for me to sit here and tell you what you
should have done you know
it's kind of like uh you know when you
when you watch a
a football game or something like that
and once it ends
and whatever the game plan was didn't
work out but dude why didn't they give
it to marshall [ __ ] i don't understand
um it's easy to do that so um
i don't know what to tell you like you
know i'll be funny you got to go back
there and keep ordering sandwiches i
don't know that's [ __ ] humiliating
you might you might have to find a new
place to get a sandwich dude i got to be
honest with you i don't know how you
pull yourself out of that one
what did you say you know what [ __ ] it
oh this is what you do [ __ ] you
just walk in just kind of be a dick you
know
when she you just walk up hey sunshine
that's something
don't listen to me all my [ __ ] just
always ends up with you know there's a
reason i get heckled as much as i do
because i'm an [ __ ]
um but as far as like uh what you said
earlier because i know there's a lot of
women pulling their [ __ ] hair out
right now when you say all the woman has
to do
is be pretty and wait for the offers to
come in
um i don't know dude if you ever had a
girlfriend first of all that whole thing
of looking pretty from
my standpoint and my experience takes at
least four and a half [ __ ] hours
and um and you never know that girl
might have been giving you the stink
eye because she's a really good looking
girl and she
she has a public she has a job where she
deals with the public
so believe it or not
the amount of ugly [ __ ] out of shape
dudes who
actually don't have a problem
approaching beautiful women
uh is actually it's that it's pretty
high
i mean personally i think it's funny but
if you're a woman it's it's not as funny
and i think that's something that took
me a long time to realize
how like um uncomfortable that feeling
can be
you know because guys think dude i would
love to be standing there and women
hitting on me
but what you have to do is you got to
see how we're physically made up the
fact that a guy
you know what what if there was this
thing that physically could beat the
[ __ ] out of you
and it wanted to enter your body
[Laughter]
that's the only way to try to put
yourself and
and what if it's if you're not attracted
to it and you feel it getting angry
when you're trying to communicate that
you know you're all set
you know and then there's the option
that if they wanted to they could give
you a forearm shiver
and begin to execute their plan you know
oh jesus how do i talk myself out of
this one you know what it's like put it
this way for all the guys listening out
there if somebody said hey man
i'll give you 10 bucks this is like an
old joke i used to do my act i'll give
you 10
bucks to walk over to that birth
birthday cake and stick your finger in
it
yeah guys you you 10 bucks yeah [ __ ] it
i'll do it you know 20 bucks or whatever
just something you know
you do it you wouldn't think anything
about it whatever stick it in you take
it right back out you know you wouldn't
give a [ __ ]
what if somebody said dude i'll give you
i'll give you 20 bucks
to take that cake and put it in your ass
[Laughter]
see what i mean there'd be a difference
then you you would have some questions
you know where is that cake ben are you
gonna tell anybody
i usually don't do things like this you
know that's that's why women they
approach sex that way you know they
gotta have rules on when they're going
to [ __ ] you and all that
it's it's a did that that example i i
know on some level it made sense i'm a
little jet lagged
i haven't done that joke in a while and
i gotta admit halfway through it it
didn't even make sense to me
i'm just saying you know did i answer
your question
um so this is what you gotta do you
gotta treat uh you gotta treat women
like uh
like i treated open mics okay you just
know you're gonna bomb and eventually
you're gonna get good at it so just keep
you know
make some notes what you're gonna do the
next time that happens
you know maybe try to come up with a
couple of lines and i hope women i hope
you appreciate
uh what a [ __ ] pain in the ass it is
for a guy to get laid
you know what i mean and that's why
there's the whole um
stud [ __ ] double standard because
basically for a guy to get laid this is
what he has to go through this guy
actually has to develop skills
to get laid you know all you have to do
is show up you know
i mean for a guy the brass ring is
getting a two on one no tv credits
no my dad has a yacht you just get it
from talking [ __ ]
that is the brass ring for a guy now a
woman her first night of [ __ ] all
she'd have to do
is lay down on a pool table she could
[ __ ] every guy in the bar
it's it's not a skill it's gluttonous
you know it's gluttonous it's like
watching a fat guy eating ice cream you
never cut you don't cut them any slack
haven't you had enough um all right
um stay with girl or not all right hi
bill love the podcast thank you and in a
tough situation so i would like to know
your thoughts
i've been with a girl for five months
and a few weeks into it she mentioned
she had been in a relationship for
five years and is still friends with the
guy what the [ __ ] is this the same one
i already answered this who i've met and
who wasn't a bad dude she used to talk
to him a lot
so she seemed not over him and mentioned
that they were basically [ __ ] buddies
since breaking up
which i don't mind happening but do mind
her thinking it's no biggie to tell me
all right let me let me try and do the
math on that
she mentioned they were basically [ __ ]
buddies since breaking up
which i don't mind happening but do mind
her thinking
it's no biggie to tell me so you don't
mind if she's [ __ ] this guy in the
side
just don't bring it up wasn't there an r
b song about that
something about girl i don't want to
know something
i can't [ __ ] remember anyways it
seemed like it was a recent breakup
but when i asked her she said in a
roundabout way it was about two years
ago
about two months in she admitted that
she had last slept with him
the week after she met me which was
actually the night of the day we met up
for the first time so after our first
date
this sounds dumb but otherwise things
are good
and she's tone talking about him down
since and is a good girl different to a
lot of
ones in my past which is why i stayed
with her after that this girl's [ __ ]
your brains out
that's what's going on she likes sex
and i guarantee you she [ __ ] this guy
at least one more time after your first
date
that this that's my instinct i'm not
saying that's true that's just my
instinct
anyways it says i'm 25 and haven't had a
girlfriend before
out of not wanting to settle and enjoy
being single exactly
there we go you haven't had a girlfriend
before so you know how to set up a
relationship yeah cause you're setting
this one up
dude come on you gotta have some
self-worth here okay
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this isn't the mother you
kids she's got a [ __ ] buddy
bangs him one time after your first date
obviously she wasn't seeing fireworks
the [ __ ] is she doing with you all right
let her blow you one more time and
show her the [ __ ] door
sorry got emotional i'll let's respect
this and i'll read the rest uh though i
was
getting sick of the single life when i
got with her and we'd be bummed out with
the prospect of getting laid less than
once a month yeah
you know something you're both using
each other
uh you're five months in i really hope
you're not in love with this girl
said i have graduated and want to move
out of our city partly to move in with a
really good friend who i miss who lives
interstate and she still has one year to
go and doesn't seem keen on moving
in your words based on that one incident
i think i already told you
i don't think she's going to be the
mother of my children here he is and
i'll always think
of it when i tell people how we met i
feel i could be missing out
on advancing my career and being with my
best friend
as i've grown apart from my other
friends as well as getting out of my
shitty small town do you think i should
move out and cut this thing short abs
are [ __ ] lootly and you know you
should
get out of your shitty small town [ __ ]
this this girl
she's gonna be in that same bar every
[ __ ] christmas when you come home to
visit your parents
okay she's gonna be there and every year
her face is gonna get a little fatter
and she might have more
ink on her [ __ ] arm and you are going
to be moving on with your life
all right and then one day you're not
going to want to go back to that bar
you're just going to drive by it
and you're going to be like i wonder if
she's in there and you're not going to
give a [ __ ] because the girl your your
dreams is going to be in your passenger
seat
you're going to drive right by on this
perfectly [ __ ] snow-covered road
there's a picture for you but that's
only going to happen if you dump this
[ __ ]
and get out of that small shitty town
all right that was a good one huh
okay advice on men hey bumbling billy
boo
uh i'll keep the question short to
rescue you from the english language
i get it i suck at reading out loud
he goes i'm a 20 oh she says oh my god
this is from
a lady
i finally get a female to write in and i
trash her right out of the gate i'm
sorry sweetheart
she says i'm a twenty-four year-old girl
and i'd like to know your best piece of
advice of understanding the human male
species many thanks but at the same time
go [ __ ] yourself well i'm sorry you
gotta be a little more specific
um but i'll give you basically
generally speaking um
uh jesus christ what do you want to know
i would
basically you want to learn how to
communicate with them better
um yeah so you're doing the right thing
you're asking another person this is
actually a very smart question
rather than sitting around with your
female friends just going i know right
what is what is that god
you sit there at a [ __ ] wine bar
whining
this is what you do you go across enemy
lines and you ask
you know a traitor like me to read from
the playbook
all right how guys communicate
i can't say that we just say what we're
thinking because we
we have liars and passive aggressive
people and uh
meandering little man boys but generally
speaking uh the thing that confuses us
the most i did a bit i can't remember if
i did it on the special but
one time i was driving with nia
and i said hey i want to get a chocolate
shake you're going by this diner
and she freaks out she's like oh my god
they make the best chocolate shakes
i know right she goes yeah and she just
goes oh my god but they're so big
she just kept saying they're so big
and after a while i'm thinking like yeah
like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] am i gonna drink
this whole thing
and then immediately just clicked on me
like they're not big
they're standard size wait a minute she
wants
half of my shake but she doesn't want to
seem selfish
but she doesn't want all the calories of
the full shake so rather but she doesn't
want to look like
she's taking away 50 percent of my good
time
so rather than telling me that she's
trying to mind [ __ ] me into thinking
something that i drank a zillion times
with ease
is now too big you know what i mean
so that's how you guys communicate
i don't know how we communicate because
i can't just sit there and make it seem
like guys are heroes
where they would be like listen i'm
trying to lose weight so
uh can i have half your shake
um the only thing i tell you is you're
24 years old uh
you shouldn't understand them you
shouldn't understand guys but it's hard
for me to
i don't know what you're asking please
write back
please write back advice on men part two
just do that again just [ __ ] right
back
ask me something more specific and i can
help you out but it's great that at 24
you're actually
smart enough to ask guys to explain
um let's see best piece of advice
is a great piece of advice uh learn how
to cook
all right as stereotypical as that
[ __ ] sounds
i don't mean it in a sexist [ __ ] way
all right i don't
don't be a slob and learn how to cook
would put you ahead of eighty percent of
[ __ ] women out there
because for some reason somewhere along
edith wharton over that chick who
sewed the flag making a guy a sandwich
became this absolutely degrading [ __ ]
thing to do
yet guys still have to hold the doors
and [ __ ] buy drinks like why we don't
find that
sexist reverse sexist or whatever the
[ __ ] you'd call it
i remember one time i was downstairs i
don't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
i was doing some pain in the ass job i
was cleaning out something in the garage
and without me asking or anything
nia came downstairs with this
unbelievable sandwich she had made
pickles toothpick in it the whole
[ __ ] nine yards
and she brought like uh something to
drink downstairs too
and i stopped working and sat down it
was one of the greatest
moments of our relationship all right so
that's
some advice i'll give you is guys are
very very simple
and by simple i don't mean stupid before
you get on your [ __ ] high horse
okay it's like an old school engine you
open the hood and everything's right
there
rear wheel drive it's not turned to the
side jammed into the compartment
none of that [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
basic
you just do that every once in a [ __ ]
while
guys will think i have a keeper and all
you're doing is making a [ __ ]
sandwich
and that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
have the right to vote it's [ __ ]
unreal
cooking and then you're not even cooking
all you're doing is just slapping [ __ ]
together
you're building a little [ __ ] food
house how difficult is that
that's what i don't understand like i
guess i can't understand it but like
cooking a meal for somebody is one of
the greatest things you could ever do
for him
all right i'll leave it at that so i
would say something simple like that
this is how simple guys are if you
actually every once in a while
just said hey you want a beer and you
actually got up and went to the fridge
and got a beer
and brought it up put it in a [ __ ]
frosted mug i mean personally speaking
i'm ready to go paint the house
because that little move there i feel
like a [ __ ] king that's all it takes
that's all it takes very simple
you know let him head out with his
friends once a week
if they come over and they watch the
game and you're not into the game
leave go in the other room
or be a good [ __ ] and hang
but don't ruin his good [ __ ] time
jesus i'm on a roll here now here's
another one
uh trying to limit the amount of
horrific [ __ ] you're gonna drag him to
now he's he's obligated to go to some of
it but he has to have
just set it up and just say listen
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that you do that
i'm not going to be into
right like tailgating on a golf course
peeing in a porta potty
before before a football game that you
don't give a [ __ ] about i don't want to
be there for that
so i get to tap out of that all right
and then the guy
he gets to tap out of like
i don't know like what have i i tapped
out one time uh neil wanted to take me
to somebody's birthday party they were
having some [ __ ] you know
we're all gonna dress like it's the gold
rush or the [ __ ] prohibition era
it's like i don't want to [ __ ] do
that and she gave me [ __ ] and i was just
i
don't want to do it she let me out of it
we laughed about it
i actually went there without a costume
i mean i made a deal we made it we made
a we
made a deal i think i told this story
i'm [ __ ] punch drunky i never know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
i showed up and i didn't wear a costume
which was hilarious because every other
guy was
[ __ ] dressed like charlie chaplin and
i show up
in street clothes and they're looking at
me like i'm a magician
and then i left early because that's
right because i would have watched the
celtics were playing the lakers in the
finals that year when we beat them
and i would have missed it if nia wasn't
so [ __ ] cool so that's that's what i
would do and if you actually do [ __ ]
like that
you know you put yourself
on this solid ground with the guy that
you're with
where now there's no reason for him to
be an
[ __ ] to you or be mean to you because
you're being so nice to him
it really kind of works that way it kind
of feeds off each other that's the best
i can do without a specific question
all right so there you go and you know
[ __ ] everybody who's going to say that
you know what i just
said was sexist you know go [ __ ]
yourself i don't think it's
you know you're on a date with your
woman you go and you open the car door
for you still do that [ __ ]
if i can do that you can go get me a
[ __ ] beer christ it's a twist off
what are you gonna hurt your wrist
yeah you know something that'll be my
advice stop acting like a kicker
you know how much it [ __ ] annoys me
that every time a kicker makes a tackle
he gets hurt i just [ __ ]
i just don't understand that jesus
[ __ ] christ put some cream on it and
get back out there and [ __ ] throw
your feet around
this is the response one of the
responses i got from that leg sweep
video last week and if you're new to my
podcast
there's a video up on youtube i guess i
got taken down where uh this
this guy hits on this girl she doesn't
you know
she's not having it so he gives a [ __ ]
she gives him the finger he calls her a
[ __ ] she throws a drink in his face
and he goes up you think he he's gonna
blast her in the face
and he just gives a let or her a [ __ ]
leg sweep
that uh it should have been done in
mandalay bay in las vegas
it was [ __ ] tremendous all right here
we go so uh this this woman wrote me she
goes uh bill i can't believe you didn't
notice that she was visited with
violent behavior first this is the girl
in the video
um because i was sitting there saying i
thought the video was funny because the
girl threw the drink in his face
and even though you should never hit a
woman i just think that's outrageous
in life to think that you can throw a
drink in somebody's face i just know if
i did it within two seconds i would be
on the ground getting [ __ ] pummeled
and uh i don't know there was just
something funny about it so anyway she
goes i can't believe you didn't notice
that she was visited with violent
behavior first watch it again
and you'll see him violently poke at her
all right first of all how [ __ ]
hilarious is that violently have you
ever heard that expression in your life
violently poked there's no such thing as
being violently poked
all right it's called stab that's
you know that's fine actually my gym
teacher used to violently poke me in the
chest to [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucker um he didn't he gave her he
gave her a little [ __ ] poke he gave
it one time to her [ __ ] shoulder
that was it he was just trying to annoy
her but anyway she says by the way
it's not very complementary to a grown
woman to be shown
that he has a crush on her by punching
her he didn't punch her
he didn't punch her anyway she goes i
can't believe you're not allowing her to
do the only thing she can toss a drink
at him
since she can't beat him up do you
honestly believe that her throwing the
drink equals his
um kick slash knock to her on the skull
shame on you you bastard
so i wrote her back i said i knew this
would uh spark some debate i respect
your point of view on it so here's mine
violently poked 41 years on this planet
i have never heard someone being
violently poked um
she threw the drink in his face because
he called her a [ __ ] then she goes that
because she goes that's right i am a
[ __ ] and then the drink is thrown
and throwing the drink in his face was
not the only thing she could have done
she could have walked away she could
have talked to whoever was in charge at
the pool
she could have talked to some of the
guys who were over there um
by her friends there were a bunch of
things she could have done but she lost
her cool
um and if you're gonna um define the
action by the guy in the video
as violently poking her then you could
also address
couldn't you also address the racial
undertones of her giving the man the
finger and stating
do you understand this in english the
reason why the video is so funny is
because the unexpected happened
he actually treated her the same way he
would have treated a man that threw a
drink in his face
so the reason men find the video funny i
think is because the amount of times
women get physical with us
and there's nothing we can do except get
punched slap or have a drink thrown in
our face
because we're never gonna hit a woman
and they know it i had a girl try to
punch me in the face in a bar
and as i'm trying as carefully as
possible to defend against getting
punched in the face
basically i'm turning my back and
covering up as this girl wailed away the
bouncer comes flying over
and what do you think who do you think
they grabbed and tossed out
um i was in an argument with the female
but so what people argue
but because of the way things are she
can take it to a physical level
while i have to try and defend myself
without getting physical with her at all
only to be dragged out by the neck you
know if they tossed her out too
i would have been fine with it but
because she's a female
she gets to throw punches have me kicked
out and she gets to stay in the bar
while they continue to serve her more
drinks so to go back to the video
um that is the world this woman is
living in i'm a girl i can do this and
nothing will happen i can throw a full
drink in someone's face
and nothing will happen well guess what
something did the exact thing
same thing that would have happened to
me and then i go on to say actually i
would have been [ __ ]
punched repeatedly in the face and the
dude's friends probably would have
jumped in too and you know what the
reaction from the others people at the
pool would have been
well you threw a drink at his face what
did you think was gonna happen
and then i guess my excuse would have
been but he poked me violently
um anyways i've never hit a woman and i
don't advocate it that guy in the video
is an animal
and i wouldn't want any woman i cared
about to ever date him but the leg sweep
the [ __ ] leg sweep was genius and
undeniably funny to me
i'm just going to read you all these
back and forth so then she goes you have
no idea what women have what women have
to put up with
all right this is where i guess i'm a
[ __ ] these guys take such personal
offense
when they're turned down he should have
walked away
i will not tolerate being touched by a
stranger in that way
and it is real a really vulnerable
feeling as a woman
and makes us angry and fearful of men
besides you didn't hear the things he
was saying
guys like that parentheses in hip-hop
style clothing
are the sleaziest of scumbags licking
their lips
nasty who's hitting on you ll cool j
why don't you [ __ ] go to a nicer
place anyways
as for the argument you had in the bar
you didn't
specify now she's talking to me this is
classic line here she goes as for the
argument you had
with that woman in the bar you didn't
specify
what it was about what what it was about
and if you were yelling in her face
as you know you probably were dot dot
dot
more violent behavior you see that
let's stop right here this is what i
love about this type of [ __ ]
anytime there's a group of people
bitching about their situation
nine times out of ten when they're
bitching
they end up doing the exact same thing
to the person that they're bitching at
that they don't want done to them look
how you assume
that immediately i'm getting hit i'm not
hitting her back i'm getting hit and
you're blaming me i'm surprised you
didn't ask me what i was wearing
was i asking for it
anyways you want to hear the story
sweetheart this this is basically
this is why this girl was punching me in
the bar all right
we're going back here about 10 years i'm
standing up now i'm going to tell this
story my dog's looking at me what's up
cleo how are you doing huh
you're a female huh you can defend
yourself you [ __ ] psycho
um this is this is what happened i was
in i was in a bar
and i was with some buddies of mine this
group of girls is next to us we're
hitting on them you know
we're making jokes we're joking around
you know you try to get women to laugh
that's what the [ __ ] you have to do
women i know you don't
you don't understand that because you
don't have to make somebody want to [ __ ]
you
okay the same way i don't know what it's
like to have to carry a [ __ ]
living thing inside of me for nine
months i understand
we all have our advantages so whatever
i'm not trying to be a douche here but
this is basically it so we're trying to
you know we're joking around or whatever
i had a couple drinks they had a couple
drinks
and one of them was dressed like she she
looked like rhoda
on mary tyler moore right so at one
point that girl goes up
and uh she goes to go to the bathroom so
i say to a friend i go jesus christ was
she
she
a big fan of mary tyler moore or what
right made a joke about what she was
wearing
so another 20 minutes goes by those
girls kind of peeled off you know we
weren't really talking to him anymore we
were uh
or maybe we kind of were i don't know
what was going on sort of that type of
[ __ ] you're talking to a girl for a
couple seconds then it's not working out
so i went back i was talking to my
friend
and i guessed when the girl came back
from the from the bathroom
her friend told her what i said
so unbeknownst to me so i'm sitting
there talking to my buddy then all of a
sudden i just hear this
this this woman yelling hey [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] right so i look over
and she's looking at me she's going hey
[ __ ] and i'm and i'm i'm
trying to process because i you know
typical me i said some [ __ ] i didn't
remember what the [ __ ]
i said and then she goes you know you're
gonna talk [ __ ] about me
when i'm not around and then i then i
kind of was
right as i'm putting it together then
she stood up and she [ __ ]
put her hand over you ever see like a
you ever see like a
center in the nba how they fight how
they can't throw they
[ __ ] throw punches like that they're
trying to [ __ ]
throw somebody out at second base that's
what she did she winds up and she's
about ready to come down on the top of
my head
so you know because she wound up i mean
if she [ __ ] threw a jab she would
have [ __ ] blasted me right in the
face and i gotta admit that would have
been [ __ ] hilarious but because she
went up and over
i was able to get my arm up in time and
i saw it i sort of like caught her wrist
so now i instantly i recognize the
situation i'm like oh [ __ ]
okay this girl is not going to stop and
i don't want to get hit in the face i
can't squeeze her wrist too hard all
this shit's going through my head and i
know
even though i can't see it i know the
bouncers are on their way over and i
know what the [ __ ] gonna happen
so all i'm doing is holding her wrist as
she's [ __ ]
clawing at my side i'm sort of turned to
the side
and of course my buddies aren't doing
anything they're sort of just looking at
this point because it happened so fast
and i'm going whoa i was going hey hey
hey i can't remember what i was saying i
was just
this just too much [ __ ] was going on i i
i couldn't
i couldn't formulate anything to say to
get this girl to stop but she just kept
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was like punching me in the side and
then the [ __ ] bouncers come over
and they [ __ ] grab me of course
because i'm the guy
i i just blew my mind i i i'm [ __ ]
i almost have my back turned to this
girl with my my hand up
and she's wailing away and they they
immediately go to me
and i get [ __ ] tossed out you know so
let me ask you this in her world was she
justified
for taking it to a physical level
because i [ __ ] made fun of her outfit
you know
that's was my point about that video i
don't think you should hit a woman
the reality of that video that i that i
watched there on youtube
is that they're both [ __ ] and
they're both stubborn
and what happened there is what you saw
when you get two stubborn people who
want to get the last word in
okay he hits on her she tells him to go
[ __ ] himself not saying she literally
said that but she basically says no
so he couldn't handle it so he probably
he starts it i'm gonna i'll go i'll give
you that he
starts it okay and he wants to get the
last word in
so she can't let him right he should
have walked away but he didn't
that's you know right in the beginning
he didn't so he gives her [ __ ]
then she should have walked away
realized he was a psycho she doesn't she
[ __ ] gives him the finger
then he should have walked away but he
doesn't he pokes her she should have
walked away then
but she doesn't she [ __ ] throws a
drink at his face
he should have [ __ ] walked away he
doesn't he [ __ ] goes up and he leg
sweeps her
it's just one of those deals two [ __ ]
[ __ ] who probably
should be breeding and make a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] kid and then we'll have
another dog the bounty hunter huh you
see how that math works out
so anyways um i you know i don't know
sometimes i feel like i'm saying [ __ ]
and people don't get what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i'm not saying that you
should go around hitting a woman i'm
just saying
you know guys should never hit women but
women shouldn't take advantage of that
by doing outrageous [ __ ] like throwing a
drink in somebody's face that is [ __ ]
outrageous
behavior and be honest as a female if
another female walked up to you and
threw a drink in your face what would
you do
huh what would you do would you just go
oh that was mature
do you feel better about yourself is
sprite is dripping down the [ __ ]
your bangs whatever [ __ ]
you got that rachel bob haircut from
friends ah look at me
look at me with that [ __ ] check
reference um
whatever
[Music]
all right advice bill since you've uh
you've given great advice on
relationships in the past i'm wondering
if you can do it for me
i've been with this girl this lady of
mine for years
and we're planning on getting married oh
geez uh
we're both only 20 years old i'm a
college dropout since i'm certainly
a more blue collar individual she is
going to college
to work with children we both work
full-time jobs mine being the night
shift
in a warehouse selecting orders to go to
individual stores
stressful and physically challenging uh
here's being hers being a phone
answering day job from eight to five
working with customers in a graphic
design shop boring and easy
okay he's defined his job is stressful
and physically challenging
and her job is boring and easy never
underestimate how
tedious a boring job can be i'd rather
do your job
walking around breaking balls look at
his [ __ ]
shirt dude [ __ ] queer drive by on the
[ __ ]
forklift right you guys start a softball
league you have a great time rather than
sitting there having your ass fall
asleep in a cubicle
listening to people [ __ ] because they
can't figure out how to work their set
it and forget it
grass is always greener my friend why
don't i shut my [ __ ] pie hole and
read the rest of this all right
since we started dating she seemed to do
everything to keep me interested
uh make me breakfast in the mornings on
some on some days
go to concerts with me when she didn't
necessarily like the music
um the whole works but i've noticed that
she
without she's without question just been
lacking in the care department she just
sits and watches tv every night and eats
and complains about gaining weight
i come home in the morning to do dirty
dishes to do the dirty dishes that piled
up in the sink
from her having friends over while i'm
at work for the night
and get yelled at for not cleaning them
when i saw them sitting there but i had
no part in making them dirty
dude what the [ __ ] you can't have that
she leaves clothes laying around every
room in the house
and that's not even how uh she is with
me
she has seemed to develop some kind of
self-righteousness where everything that
she
where everything that she
yeah dude you i really gotta proofread
these people so many spelling bee
mistakes she has seemed to develop some
kind of self-righteousness
where everything that she says
throughout the day should be my main
concern
and i should go out of my way to make
her life easier
i do her college homework i take care of
the two thousand dollar dog i bought for
her
i work on her car when when she nearly
runs
the damn wheels off the thing and i do
chores for her family
she volunteers me for dude she has your
balls in a little that you know that
little engagement ring you bought her if
you bother yet your balls are in there
too
the next part is the icing on the cake
she goes
as far as to dictate what time i have to
go to bed and wake up in the morning
um eat uh evenings since i work at
nights uh what
what i can and can't spend money on who
i can hang out with what days i can see
friends and require me to call her every
time i arrive at work and text her in
the middle of the night when i get off
work
and request her and i request her to do
nothing outside of what she does on her
day-to-day routine
to sum all that up i feel like she's
forcing me into a cookie mold guy
when i actually let her make her own
decisions like some strange thing called
an
adult all right i'm gonna stop right
here dude because this is just gonna be
more [ __ ] misery all right
this is this is what i've said this
before on the podcast you have to i
don't give a [ __ ]
how good the woman is that you're with
you really have to be careful because
all this [ __ ] you see on tv where women
are just constantly there's all this
[ __ ] information
out there about how guys are [ __ ] to
women
there's just reams of it and there needs
to be because guys
are [ __ ] to women so women i think
are more aware
or at least they should be more aware
because they got all these [ __ ]
goddamn shows with
either from one to four [ __ ] sitting
around bitching about guys
and all the [ __ ] that we do but
there's no show on tv where you have
four guys just sitting around a coffee
table
you know drinking some hot cocoa with
some pillows and wearing sweaters and
their favorite shoes
talking about you know not losing
yourself in a relationship that's what
you've done here
all this [ __ ] that she's doing is your
fault
okay and what's great about being a guy
is you can blame the victim
which is why we're better problem
solvers all right
this is your fault this is all on you
you don't like any of this [ __ ] you have
to sit down and talk to her
okay you you you're not required to call
her you can go to bed when you [ __ ]
want to go to bed
and you can just sit there and tell it
you did those dishes you clean it up
okay now here's the point this is the
key with
this is what you gotta do you can't be
mean
there's no reason to be mean here
there's no reason to yell
there's no reason to be angry okay all
three of those things is what she wants
you to do
because because she knows she's gonna
know she's [ __ ] wrong
if you if you if you made the dishes
dirty and every day you're telling me to
clean them up you treat me like i'm
[ __ ]
alice on the goddamn brady bunch
everybody knows that that's [ __ ]
wrong
so what women do when they're [ __ ]
wrong is they try
to make the argument about something
else all right
so she's gonna do that anyways
so but you're gonna make it easy if
you're angry and you yell at her and you
call her [ __ ] names
so what you gotta do is you gotta you
gotta keep keep your [ __ ] cool
that's what you gotta do keep your
[ __ ] cool and say listen
i worked all night i don't think it's
fair that you tell me to come home and i
have to do these dishes when you made
these dishes dirty yourself i don't
think it's fair to me
to come home in the morning and have a
sink full of dirty dishes
that not only you you and your friends
made dirty
that's unacceptable to me that you want
me to wash those that's unacceptable i'm
not doing it
you have to wash those i'll wash my
dirty dishes i'm not doing that
all right and then then let her flip out
let her pout let her slam the [ __ ]
cabinets
let her not [ __ ] you just don't back
down rub one out who gives a [ __ ]
it's just an urge you've already banged
her you're not missing anything who
gives a [ __ ]
but don't get angry alright and then
just do
do to her what she did to you just just
reclaim that territory
you're not doing that you're not doing
that anymore all right start with the
[ __ ] dishes
and then start with this and you know
you can actually tag that argument
and just saying now that we're on this
topic of discussing things
i'm going to go to bed when i want to go
to bed
i just it makes me feel like a child
when you're telling me when to go to bed
i know when to go to bed
all right now that i've aired two
complaints how about you give me a
couple of you got anything you want to
say to
me and just stay cool then when she hits
you with some [ __ ] if you don't like it
tell her you know
i was going to say to go [ __ ] herself to
you know i don't know what whatever
you know what [ __ ] that last advice just
go with the dishes thing first it's
unacceptable that's it
if you bring up something else then you
then it looks like you have all this
resentful [ __ ] and then she'll try and
spin it like
well if you're feeling all this why
don't you [ __ ] say anything because
you're a [ __ ]
that's what's going to happen and then
you're going to lose the argument and
the next thing you know
to make up for it you're not going to be
getting any [ __ ] from her and you're
gonna be doing a whole sink full of
[ __ ] dishes that you didn't dirty
all right moving on but sir you have all
the power there just keep your [ __ ]
cool
all right advice uh dear billy bob burr
uh need some girl advice i recently
struck up conversation with a very
attractive young
lady on the train the other day
we talked for practically the whole 45
minute train ride
i'm 28 but she was only 20. despite the
age difference
she was very cool and we talked about
stand-up comedy and how we are both
fans of you all right
so what are we talking about here this
is weird well said you brought me into
it
get me out of there when my stop arrived
i left without asking for her number
because i didn't want to be
that guy what guy the guy who finds love
the guy
gets laid either way you're that guy
you were that guy you were that guy that
didn't ask for a number
so he goes now i'm regretting it she
told me where she works
uh retail and i want to go there and ask
her out
so do you think it will come across
creepy or sweet if i just showed up
for a work unannounced she might not
even be working at the time but i could
leave my number with the co-worker do
not do that
any advice love the podcast go [ __ ]
yourself uh i
you know it's not creepy at all you
coming in with a raincoat you don't want
to make eye contact
yeah that's going to be creepy but if
you come walking in and just be like
listen it's been
it's been bugging me i don't remember me
i met you on the bus blah blah blah
oh yeah yeah whatever they just say
listen it's been bugging me from the
second i got off the bus that i didn't
ask you for your number i wanted to ask
you for your number but i didn't want to
come off like a creep
uh you know i'd love to take you out
sometime just very simple very honest
all right don't be all fidgety and
awkward you know just [ __ ] go in
there and just
state your case all right
now if she's not working there don't
stand outside the place
you know fogging up the [ __ ] windows
waiting for her to show up
just come walking in and just say hey is
so-and-so here
no well when does she work again blah
blah blah
you know all right oh cool all right
thank you whatever who can i say he's
asking ah the creepy guy from the bus
[Music]
um whatever yeah i would just go about
it that way but absolutely do that and
that whole [ __ ] thing hey i don't
want to be that guy
uh you be that guy be the guy that asks
for what he wants
be respectful of other people but you
got to be the guy
all right or you got to be the lady
either way
um you got to beat that [ __ ] thought
out of your head you can be so
respectful
and so like not wanting to rock the boat
that you never even [ __ ]
you know get what you want in life all
right because
life doesn't give a [ __ ] whether your
dreams come true or not all right
and a lot of the dreams that you have
this isn't one of them but a lot of the
dreams that you have
like i always find it funny that people
pray to a higher power
oh please let me get this job please let
me blah blah and all that type of [ __ ]
the way this whole [ __ ] world was set
up if one person made it
is if basically if you got a roof over
your head and you're eating every day
and you have
drinking water your dream is fulfilled
so to sit there and ask for a corner
office of this person you're really just
clogging up their phone lines
is that nuts i don't know that's how i
look at it all right
uh dear bill um
bill i met you after a show in
pittsburgh the black guy with the hot
latina we laughed about my shoes
matching my outfit
welp my beautiful girlfriend for the
past three years has a little bit of
insecurity
insecurity issues um
a lot of those absolutely gorgeous women
do you know why it is it's because
their level i'm without even reading
this [ __ ] the reason why i think a lot
of them are [ __ ] insecure
is because because they're beautiful
and that goes away after a while so the
clock is just [ __ ] ticking
you know if you're just some regular
douchebag
like me there's no pressure going back
to your [ __ ] high school reunion i
mean the expectations are so [ __ ] low
you know it's easy to surpass him like
oh geez he didn't get fat
this guy's awesome
but if you're a [ __ ] hot chick it can
just it can only
go downhill and i also think that they
have the same insecurity a rich guy has
where rich guys like this woman's just
with me because of my money
not because of who i am i think that
they have the insecurity
this person's just with me because of my
ass and today's
hey all right for some really odd reason
she feels the need for me to prove to
her that i love her
whenever we're in a public setting so
recently during some christmas shopping
uh she got upset that i wouldn't hold
her hand as we walked through the mall
she proceeded to catch one of the one of
her spicy latin attitudes with me
um see now if you were white and you
said that and you said that on tv you
would have to apologize for nine weeks
when you lose your job
why does it have to be spicy are you
saying that latino people
are like their peppers um all right i'm
gonna stop commenting and just plow
through this okay so i handle
handle uh the situation like a g
parentheses gentlemen and completely
ignored her ass
um until we got into the car and i
finally had enough of her telling me how
i don't love her
and how she wants me to love her
oh i don't love her how she wants me to
love her and how unaffectionate of a man
i am
and you know what dude that right there
is probably how you got this hot girl
because you weren't the first guy
sitting there with your tongue hanging
out of your mouth
you acted like you didn't even give a
[ __ ] which fed into her insecurity of
like oh my god is the expiration date
hit
am i not hot anymore um
look at me commenting again all right i
swear these [ __ ] are so unappreciate
i'm unappreciative
this is funny you call them [ __ ] why
can't these [ __ ] understand how much
i appreciate their ass
uh every weekend bill we do something
dinner movies plays etc but because she
has a vag
she has to find something to complain
about i think it's because women have
this trait where they feel a strong need
to be
miserable no dude you know what's going
on he's just spoiling her
you're taking it to dinner movies plays
every [ __ ] weekend she's
now she's come to expect it you know
what i mean
it's just become part of a routine it's
not special anymore so now you have to
do something extra special
because special isn't special
you know that's what i i do you know
what
i'm about to whisper this [ __ ] we're up
in san francisco right i lit up my
credit cards this christmas all right
my girl had a great [ __ ] christmas
all right
it's three days later we're up in
[ __ ] san francisco she wants to go
shopping
i'm like for what you didn't get enough
you know so she knows i'm right so what
does she do
she tells me she wants a goddamn candle
okay
because it's not expensive but she'll
still feel like she got something
because i don't know what it is they
always got a few they always got to get
stuff there's always got to be some sort
of a goodie bag and you know what i
wouldn't get it for
i wouldn't get it for okay you're done
no i'm not it's over
my credit cards are still glowing i'm
not getting you [ __ ]
and you know she's cool as hell so she
just kept laughing
because i was being unbelievably rude
and i was being really loud
i was just joking around and uh but
still
that's the thing i just kept saying i
spoil you i'm you know we're shutting it
down for a while
you're not getting anything until
valentine's day
you know you want something i'll get you
a little bag of fritos what do you think
about that maybe something to wash it
down with
[Laughter]
and then what they do is they
immediately get mad and then all you do
is you don't take the bait
they want you to get mad so then they
can turn it into a fight about something
else because they know you're [ __ ]
right
all right so let her be mad all you got
to do you just got to stay
[ __ ] calm well let's see what this
guy does
uh so anyways he goes so we are driving
along the highway
leaving the mall and she's still
bitching and finally i tell her you know
what
if you don't like the way i express my
love for you then step
off uh gotta read that quote like a
black man
i can't i'm not even going to try to uh
so immediately
i actually read that i read that like a
douchey east coast white guy didn't
[ __ ] step off
uh how did you if you don't like that
[ __ ] then step off
[ __ ] how was that was that good i know
it wasn't well don't ask me to do it
all right plowing ahead you know what i
might have like a [ __ ] substitute
black guy for when black guys write some
[ __ ] in here so you guys can read it the
way you're supposed to say it other than
that
you're getting [ __ ] a cracker ass
read and you're gonna have to live with
it
all right so immediately after that i
said after i said that
this [ __ ] starts throwing these
accurate and quick ass
pakio combos she's punching you
mind you i'm doing 65 miles per hour
down the highway
trying not to hit the guardrail while at
the same time getting this crazy [ __ ]
off me
luckily i didn't crash my year old
mercedes
this guy's hilarious come on dude do you
love this girl is she just another
accessory
um my year old mercedes with the
corinthian leather uh i get pulled over
get pulled over or god forbid seriously
injure us
i mushed the hell out of her and held
her face against the passenger window
totally acceptable totally the mush
is the gentleman move you can't punch
her you just hold her head up against
the glass
you know so the people on the other side
get to see where her face looks in a fun
house mirror
in order to decrease her reach while
steering the car on the highway
and absorbing her manly combos got to
give it to her
the [ __ ] had a mean right um
so if you can picture me driving i can
totally picture this dude i've lived
this
so you can picture me driving down the
highway in a bright red
mercedes okay not i didn't ever had a
mercedes
it was more in a 83 ford ranger with
black vinyl seats
[Laughter]
um swerving like some drunk in and out
of lane
staring with one hand and stiff-arming
the [ __ ] out of my girl as if i'm posing
for the heisman trophy
after she stopped beating my face in she
had the nerve to say i hit her
and heard her worse by pressing her face
against the glass are you [ __ ]
kidding me
this [ __ ] almost took both of our lives
long story short
as soon as i was able to come to a safe
and complete stop
i kicked a [ __ ] out and haven't heard
from her since this was three weeks ago
and it's all for the best that type of
girl can never be satisfied which is
something i've learned the hard way
over the past three years but this was
the straw that did it so my question for
you is was i
wrong in this situation and do i owe her
an apology
no and no
all right all you can do is break down
your game plan all right this is where
you [ __ ] up
you took the bait all right she kept
bitching
and bitching and bitching and bitching
trying to make you mad
she was trying she got you to do exactly
what she wanted you to do
so that gave her an excuse to do what
she wanted to do
which was [ __ ] flip out and yell all
right
that's what they do when they know they
don't have a [ __ ] leg to stand on and
they know they're wrong
what they then try to do you know not
all of them
they're not in every situation but when
they're not going to be an adult and
just say you know what
you're right i'm being [ __ ] crazy
right now i apologize
okay when they're not going to take that
adult route
what they then do is they just push your
buttons and they just try to make you
mad and they just keep pushing you and
pushing it
and pushing it and pushing it until you
then flip out
and say something [ __ ] crazy like
well if you don't like it then why don't
you get the [ __ ] out
and then they flip out
all right so what you got to do is in
the future
is you you just don't take the bait you
got to recognize
you know they're doing they're doing the
[ __ ] dennis rodman thing to you
they're baiting you into a penalty
that's all they're doing okay
and the ref always sees the retaliation
that's basically
it's the same [ __ ] thing so in the
future
just don't get mad it will drive them up
the [ __ ] wall and you won't believe
the amount of arguments you're going to
start winning
because in their effort to piss you off
they're going to cross
like 10 other lines all right
now when they cross 10 other lines if
you take the bait and then go
even further down the road that's all
that's remembered in the end
as you then try and piece together who
said what when but if they go
if they cross 10 lines and you don't
take the bait they are 10 lines beyond
where the [ __ ] they should be
and you got them dead to rights you just
have to maintain your [ __ ] cool
now getting back to this other [ __ ]
is you do not owe her a [ __ ] apology
all right it's absolutely [ __ ]
ridiculous
it's absolutely childish and you can't
as an adult
expect somebody to not hit you if you're
hitting them
alright she's basically asking you to
extend
a common human to human courtesy that
she's not extending to you so she
can go [ __ ] herself you definitely
i don't know if you made the right move
now i don't know if you walk around
calling her a [ __ ] and that type of
thing this is you
just trying to be a tough guy going in
this [ __ ] said this and this
you know this [ __ ] said that uh
that's another thing don't go around
calling them [ __ ] because that did
that just kills your argument don't ever
call them bad names all right
just hold your ground don't lose your
[ __ ] cool
and let them go through their whole
little [ __ ] histrionics trying to get
you to take the [ __ ] bait
all right and as long as in the
relationship you admit when you're wrong
and you sincerely apologize
they don't have a [ __ ] leg to stand
on when you're right and you're going to
start winning arguments
and you're going to be happier there you
go
all right and other than that
i don't know stop dating psychos
all right here we go another creepy
email
yet another creepy email uh interested
in younger girl of legal age
okay dear billy blue balls
in your last podcast and many others you
talked about what you think
is an acceptable age gap between people
in a relationship
oh by the way that you know divide by
two and add seven
that that guy was taking credit for i
like to do this
you [ __ ] hack the french came up with
that
those stinky smelly sons of [ __ ] came
up with that one
um actually the younger french people
don't smell it's the older ones
that have just not given in to good lord
those smelly menage tois
um is that you or me i currently have a
moral dilemma that relates to the topic
in which as a 20 year old i'm thinking
about pursuing a relationship with the
girl who's 16. dude
when what where in the [ __ ] world is
she legal
she asked me out recently and i'm
toiling with the decision as to whether
or not i should take her
up on her offer uh
i'd like to know what your thoughts are
about this before you jump to conclusion
and start hating my guts let me give you
a little back story
where i live the age of consent is
sixteen
so this is a hundred percent legal
you know what i would do a search to try
to figure out where that is because you
conveniently didn't tell you
but if i did i'd end up on some list
because i would be searching where is 16
legal to [ __ ] somebody if you go with
the french
divide your age in half that's ten you
add seven
seventeen you're coming in under the
[ __ ] wire
uh i'm a very young looking 20 year old
so what ralph macchio ought to be able
to [ __ ] a 16 year old what the [ __ ]
gonna
oh my what when did this become to the
the uh to catch a predator podcast
i'm a very young looking 20 year old and
can easily pass off as a high school
student you
[ __ ] creep if you didn't look at my
id you'd think me and this girl are the
same age
she's highly intelligent and very mature
what is mature in your world there
aren't just pictures in her book
i know pedophiles like to use this
phrase a lot to justify their actions
but i can have better conversations with
this girl than most girls my age
and older i wait a minute this is a lady
i just turned 20 and for much of the
time
we are only three years apart
okay wait a minute
now i didn't expose me for being a
sexist
individual here all right
so you're both women
i i need i need uh [ __ ] he's still
sleeping i need a [ __ ] female's
advice here
you know
because uh the way you're set up
physically
this is how dumb i am okay and don't
judge me here
help me because of the way you set up
physically for some reason it doesn't
seem as bad
you know that you can't uh
you're not gonna [ __ ] him you know
you're just gonna kiss him and pet him
and laugh at him that's just so [ __ ]
creepy
um oh wait there's more excuses here i'm
sorry
um i just turned 20 and for much of the
time we're only three years apart
she's probably much more experienced
sexually than me as she
had previously been in a serious
relationship for quite some time jesus
christ when did this girl start [ __ ]
and i've never had a relationship that
lasted more than a month or two
never in my entire life including grade
school
have i ever had a relationship or gone
on a date with someone younger than me
this is an entirely new territory and i
guess you can see why i'd be
apprehensive you keep painting yourself
as the victim
i really like this girl and she must
like me but
i don't know what my next step should be
there's no one i can really talk to
about this
without them jumping to conclusions so
any advice you can give me would be help
helpful thanks bill go [ __ ] yourself ps
please come to saskatchewan okay there
we go
uh sometime during your travels you got
fans up here and we're aching for some
high quality stand up um
all right well what's weird about this
email is where i live 16 is not the age
of consent
all right so this is creeping me out um
now let me make sure you are a female i
didn't read that wrong she's highly
intelligent i know pen falsies phrase
but i can only have a better
conversation where did i think that she
was a woman
i'm a very young looking 20 year old and
can easily pass off as a high school
student
if you didn't look at my id you think me
and this girl are the same
age where did i think that this was a
woman am i out of my [ __ ] mind
ah jesus christ
now i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] to think look if you're a guy and
you're going to make this [ __ ] move
i i just i i don't i i can't get out of
the fact that it's [ __ ] illegal in my
world
and i use the french thing cut in half
plus seven
whatever you are man woman hermaphrodite
just be like look talk to me in 11
months
all right when you turn 17. and i guess
that's legal up even more legal and i
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know you
know go make a snowman with them
uh her i don't [ __ ] i don't
i don't want to read these anymore all
right i don't want to be like giving
there's a yeah people down the street
and i'm a young
14 year old and i was you know
i don't like doing the stuff people my
age do i still like playing with
matchbox cars [ __ ] creepy
all right a little bit of advice here
listen to this [ __ ] situation this
guy got himself into
um all right bill my girlfriend is 10
years older than me oh jesus
she has two kids oh jesus and has been
married
and divorced twice
dude what the [ __ ] i'm 26
jesus christ college graduate
has any of this made any sense to any of
you would anybody else be out there 26
college [ __ ] graduate have a
girlfriend 10 years older than you with
two kids who's been married and divorced
twice
good god man he goes i consider myself
somewhat intelligent
i'm sure you are but not in this area um
by that i mean you should have no
problem understanding this email well
yeah i know everybody trashes me i know
i know i'm the worst when it comes to
reading this [ __ ]
so anyways here we go he says four weeks
ago
i found text messages to some dude on my
girlfriend's phone
that although innocent enough made it
clear
that whoever she was texting was on more
familiar grounds
than just some work colleague or a
friend
jesus christ dude is there going to be a
happy ending here
i confronted her about it and it
predictably led to a lot of finger
pointing we went back and forth
and uh for a few days and aired out our
grievances
but it seemed agreeable
now he makes i guess point number two oh
two more weeks passed by
and lo and behold i find more text
messages from the same
[ __ ] guy at first i tell myself okay
maybe she can't break things off with
this dude so quickly
jesus christ dude you know sometimes
liberal thought is a is a great thing
like let's have a fair [ __ ] trial for
somebody
before we hang them from the nearest
tree but then there's times it's [ __ ]
stupid this is just
liberal thought to the i mean how much
of a benefit of the doubt can you give
somebody
you know so you go so i confront her
about it and this leads to another round
of finger-pointing
at which point she tells me to pack my
[ __ ] and leave
well dude i'm gonna tell you right now
before i read the rest of it that's
[ __ ] great
you didn't have to do any dirty work
you're out you're [ __ ] out
so anyways he goes we're separated for a
week when she asked me to come back and
move in
dude this chick is a [ __ ] psycho here
we go
we talk about our future together how
sorry she is
to have done that to me etc etc for
[ __ ] sakes we even talking about
getting married when things finally
[ __ ] evened out
i was full of piss and vinegar and felt
vindicated vindicated
that i was the one wronged in the whole
situation and
she was actually making good by taking
responsibility for what she had done
through taking responsibility would have
been [ __ ] after
dude the second you see those weird
texts just get i'm telling you right now
just get out of the relationship
there isn't oh sorry sorry about the
no that's it it's over it's [ __ ] over
um but whatever you're 26
i guess you still haven't learned i was
dumb in my 20s so
here we go let's read the rest of this
um all was well and good
until she didn't come home this thursday
night november 11th
she came in friday morning with no
explanation no apology no nothing
she asked me to give her some more time
but i decided to cut bait
and just get the [ __ ] out of the
situation hang on a second everybody
sorry i had to give a little applause
break there of course
now i'm racked with guilt of leaving the
woman i loved and lived with for the
past
five [ __ ] year you got with her when
you were 21 dude
she was 31 wait let's do the math she
was 31 you were 21 she was already
married twice
all right this chick's a psycho and you
know what that means she's [ __ ] great
in bed
you were 21 she [ __ ] devastated you
with [ __ ] her [ __ ] right
best blow job you ever had isn't that
what happened and next thing you know
you were too [ __ ]
too young and dumb and you you fell for
a
yeah jesus christ he stayed there for
five [ __ ] years
so anyway i guess this chick still
calling him telling she still wants to
get back together
i feel like every time i sack up and do
what i think is best for me she wants me
back
and every time when i do what's best for
us as a couple
she uses that as an opportunity to [ __ ]
with me all over again
yes yes you're absolutely right
listen to your gut this guy see
he knows the [ __ ] answers he's
listening to his gut good [ __ ] man
um is this is it just that chicks can't
handle a guy that is emotionally
invested
or do i just happen to be dealing with
one of those
sociopaths that doesn't give a [ __ ]
what she does so long as it suits her in
the moment yes
there's plenty of [ __ ] good women
that's not plenty good women there's
good women out there
all right just like good good man's hard
to find this finding a good woman is
also difficult
all right but no you happen to be
dealing with an absolute [ __ ]
sociopath
all right she had a [ __ ] up childhood
something happened to her she either got
touched her [ __ ] dad took off
i don't or she just got the [ __ ] she
got one of those bad brains
you know i can tell you guys my theory
on that the a brain the b
brain and the c brain the a brain is the
genius the b brain is the uh dude he's a
good [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know fitzy and then the c
brain is you're a [ __ ]
mouth-breathing [ __ ]
all right and when it comes to being a
sociopath
that's like just uh that's just like
getting an option on the car
all brains come with that option it's
all available like satellite radio
you know you get satellite radio and a
[ __ ] bentley
you can also get it my [ __ ] prius all
right
so did that make any [ __ ] sense you
got a sociopath with the [ __ ]
she could even have the a brain that's
the sad thing about having a [ __ ] up
childhood she could actually be a
[ __ ] genius
but she's got that sociopath [ __ ] so
tell her to go call [ __ ] doctor drew
all right
and you get the [ __ ] out of the
relationship so anyways he say
i'd imagine you'd agree that i did the
right thing
uh but it always helps to get a little
bit of better perspective on it dude i
totally understand
you've been in a five-year relationship
you're emotionally invested in this [ __ ]
so you know what the right thing to do
is but your emotions keep [ __ ] with
you
all right so what you got to know is
just look going through a breakup
is painful all right it's not going to
not be painful
but just because it's painful doesn't
mean that it's not the right thing to do
you are 100 [ __ ] percent
doing the right [ __ ] thing you're 26
year old years old
you're in the prime of your [ __ ] life
all right
get out of that situation okay she's 10
years older than you
by the time you're 29 she's going to be
hitting [ __ ] menopause
all right or something like that
whatever sliding into it i have no
[ __ ] idea what she's going to be
doing
she's going to be wearing those mom
jeans at that point
if she's not already which i don't think
she is
she's probably that [ __ ] you know
that uh
that anorexic cougar look you know
or they got a varicose vein in between
their [ __ ] you can see their
breastplate
uh jesus christ bill stay on topic yeah
so dude just get out of that
hang out with your [ __ ] fellas you
know hang on your buddies go out and
[ __ ]
have some beers join a gym get [ __ ]
shredded
and go out start talking [ __ ] when
you're ready but
don't go back to that man you dodged a
[ __ ] bullet
the fact that you were with her for five
years and you didn't knock her up
and you got out of it and even after
five years you're only 26 years old you
made the best
[ __ ] move you're gonna make all right
and now this is what you need to do
you've been in a relationship for five
years
you need to be single for at least a
[ __ ] year and a half
and i don't mean just be single and
[ __ ] booze
figure out what the [ __ ] you're looking
for all right and when you meet a girl
if she doesn't have it just walk banger
and leave
you know there's nothing wrong with
having a good [ __ ] time but do not
get sucked into another [ __ ]
relationship
because you're gonna cause you're gonna
have to go through this [ __ ] again
you know we're just sitting there and
you know it's [ __ ] wrong but you
don't want to go through the [ __ ]
pain of it you keep coming back it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare good for you
sir i'm [ __ ] proud of you you did the
right thing
you're sort of [ __ ] wavering because
you're going through the emotions you're
only 26 you got with her when you were
21 it's probably your first major
[ __ ] breakup
so it's acceptable that you [ __ ] up
and went back that second time but do
not go
back again and if any of your [ __ ]
friends are listening to this
don't let him do that [ __ ] all right tie
him to a [ __ ] bar stool and start
throwing drinks down his throat
bill i [ __ ] up and could use a hand
all right let's see how did you [ __ ] up
hey you old biscuit bacon [ __ ] uh i
[ __ ] this one up and could use some of
your broadcasted advice
i'm 26 year old guy living and working
in the great white north
toronto to be exact and i love your
podcasts and all that [ __ ] thank you
anyways a few months ago i started
seeing this really sweet girl
she's pretty she's thoughtful and she's
as low maintenance as a 1991 honda civic
okay it sounds like the beginning of a
horror movie everything's like [ __ ]
perfect right he literally says perfect
exclamation point she deserves to be
treated right
about a month ago i was eating in a
restaurant
with a buddy when this smoking hot
redhead comes up to me
out of the blue and says hey you're cute
take my number let's go out sometime i
should have said no
i have a girlfriend right then and there
but the excitement of having a babe
throw herself at me
was too much for me to pass up abso
[ __ ] lily it was
that's like a [ __ ] movie we're not
wired to pass that moment up i'm not
saying you go and do it but jesus
uh he said i didn't have the damn
strength to keep it in my pants
later that night after a few wobbly pops
i
texted her looking to meet up we did and
we did the deed
i felt like a piece of [ __ ]
uh yes we've all been there as men we've
all been there
and a lot of ladies too which never gets
any press because it's considered sexist
to suggest that
um here's where it's getting interesting
and slightly complicated not even 48
hours later i'm hanging out with my
girlfriend
when she gets a call from one of her
friends saying i have some bad news to
tell you
oh boy i overheard the conversation
coming from my girlfriend's phone and
knowing exactly what the bad news was i
snatched the phone from her
and proceeded to spill my guts and told
her the whole story well there you go at
least you man it up
evidently the friend that called was
roommates with the redhead and the
redhead through social media
had hunted me down and shown my picture
to her roommates
dude you can't you can't get away with
anything anymore look at this the friend
goes on to tell the redhead that i have
a girlfriend
oh dude this is what this is like you're
gonna end up with nothing here my
girlfriend
obviously was super upset but being the
sweetheart she
is and after many many i'm so sorry for
me she agreed
to let me try to make it up to her
um how did cheaters do this [ __ ] i
didn't even last 48 hours cut to two
weeks later
myself and three of my buddies since
kindergarten are on a mountaineering
expedition in peru
dude what are you [ __ ] jason bourne
what's going on here hot chicks throwing
themselves at you now you're in [ __ ]
peru
uh a trip we planned since february and
i get this panic-stricken email from my
girlfriend saying
she parentheses the redhead
had broken into my apartment and trashed
the place
see attached photos
dude what the [ __ ] women are [ __ ]
crazy
let's just say let's just say this okay
like how was she hurt she came walking
up to you
threw her [ __ ] clam at you you
[ __ ]
took it who what you're not in a
relationship with her
my voice is literally cracking a
relationship you're not in a [ __ ]
relationship with her
dude you need to prosecute this [ __ ]
woman
this has to stop this whole [ __ ]
thing that when women get upset
they can destroy property
let a guy go out and [ __ ] trash some
woman's car after she [ __ ] around on
him
he'll end up in jail and have to pay for
the [ __ ] car
everything was smashed my tv one of my
guitars she cut up my bed sheets and the
duvet
she even went so far as to throw all my
towels in the bathtub and ran the water
how do i know it was the redhead the
dumb [ __ ] left a note next to tv saying
cheaters never win or some [ __ ] like
that give me a [ __ ] break she even
bragged about the whole ordeal
to her affirmation roommate
classic guy he just writes sheesh my
boyfriend called my girlfriend called
the cops and upon my return from peru
i set up a restraining order against the
redhead you should [ __ ] char you
should
you should sue her here's the problem
all this drama has led to my girlfriend
reconsidering her willingness to give me
a second chance
dude here's the real thing anytime some
[ __ ] smoking hot girl just comes up
to you and throws it at you
you know it's a head case
go with a fake name um i think
i feel real bad about the whole
situation and want to make it work
between
us but there's this little voice in my
head says let her break up with you and
start fresh
i'm pretty confused i was gonna say that
just start over again dude
you're 26 what are you gonna you know
you got a dick this is gonna happen all
right so he goes i [ __ ] up initially
but forgiveness then got [ __ ] with and
the
forgiveness was retracted anyways i hope
your your sage advice
is half as good as those [ __ ] pies
you make thanks a lot and go [ __ ]
yourself
yeah dude you know what you got to do
you got to walk and you got to have this
crazy redheaded [ __ ]
pay for your [ __ ]
all right jesus christ she takes no
responsibility in that just walking
around throwing a [ __ ] [ __ ] at
everybody i mean what the [ __ ] you
think's gonna happen
it's you know as a guy you could walk
around throwing your dick at [ __ ]
people for
for years and not get anything
this is why there's the double standard
you know if a guy does it he's a stud
because he has to convince people just
the way we're said it let's just it's
the way we're set up
okay women are no better than guys it's
what it is is the way they're set up
anatomically is they're letting someone
enter their body that is a major
decision
sticking your dick in something it's you
know
it's fine it's like you know it's like
putting cereal back in the cabinet i
mean you don't even [ __ ] think about
it
um i probably you know that's probably
ignorance in there uh yeah i would just
say like you know what you're right i
[ __ ] up
um that's a really big pet peeve of mine
that [ __ ] women get to do [ __ ] like
that
that you just get to walk around destroy
your [ __ ]
just [ __ ] up your tv and all that dude
and you just and your whole thing is
just like
sheesh like we're like sit we like
we're just conditioned to be like all
right that's what they do they ruin your
stuff
um dude you were 100 in the wrong you
shouldn't have done it you definitely
did a piece of [ __ ] thing
you know but that doesn't give somebody
the right to go
to break into your [ __ ] apartment
that's breaking and entering and
destroying property
she should be in jail um
this is what you do i would break up
with her and
uh i would i would yeah i would try to
take legal action against the redhead
and at some point i'd you know you want
to send her a note but don't do it just
say yeah breaking and entering you know
[ __ ] felons never win either whatever
the [ __ ] that is
um yeah dude whatever you know it
happened
and uh yeah you know what i would do if
you're 26 stay single for a while
stay single for a while go to the gym
get back in shape figure out what the
[ __ ] you want to do do you want to [ __ ]
a bunch of women
or do you want to meet the one you know
uh but i i think at this point dude you
got enough [ __ ] drama
i can't believe she gets to do that like
first of all she got laid the redhead
she got [ __ ]
laid you know she had a great [ __ ]
time
and she gets to bust up somebody's place
like a [ __ ] rock star
and then walk out of there and feel like
she's a [ __ ] hero
this is why i don't give a [ __ ] that
they make less an hour than i do
because when you add up all the [ __ ]
perks i mean it's a pretty good goddamn
deal being a woman
you know you get all your emotions out
all the [ __ ] time you get to break up
people's [ __ ]
and you get to live longer than men i
don't know what the [ __ ] problem is
you're gonna complain about an extra 79
cents
all right i'm 38 she's 19. oh jesus and
pregnant
oh jesus christ
jesus christ all right when you were
banging her were you still wearing your
high school football jacket that you
can't button anymore
oh god all right hey yo billy bloodnut
uh josh here from sydney australia uh
one of my favorite [ __ ] countries out
there
i love australia i've been there forever
um i need the advice of the world's
greatest copper wire pubes owner well
that would be me
um i'm a 38 year old man who's been
seeing a 19 year old
stunner stannah um
all right well i don't know what the uh
that would be frowned upon here
you know i mean people did it i mean
people always made fun of that [ __ ]
all right i don't know i don't know how
it works over there all right we met at
the gym
i'll never forget the day she walked in
the second i saw her my heart skipped a
beat as she put down her book bag i'm
kidding
my heart skipped a beat and i froze
amazing face
[ __ ] me eyes tiny waist and a fat ass
that hips thrust 200 kilograms jesus
this guy
is a [ __ ] creep um
i've never had a problem speaking with
women to be honest
i [ __ ] roughly 1 000 women in my years
with a few serious relationships in
between
you've had serious relationships while
[ __ ] a thousand you must've been
[ __ ] those women right through those
relationships
uh i couldn't even say hello to this
girl for three months
the whole time i thought she was 26
um i changed gyms for a week and every
day all day within that week i felt like
it would be my life's regret if i didn't
say hello
i swallowed my fears probably from
building her up in my head that three
months
and went back to the gym and finally
said hello hello her response
was the same as my energy she had been
waiting for me to say hello that whole
time
uh the next day we went for dinner and
cocktails
i found out she she was 19
an influencer with over two hundred
thousand follower
pretty good for an aussie chick and had
been living between sydney and la for a
couple of years
needless to say using the words of the
great dave chappelle
i beat the [ __ ] up you know i got to
get you know i got to tip my cap to how
unfiltered this guy is
murphy's law has it
that she falls pregnant
i don't think that's murphy's law buddy
i think that's the law of nature
if you don't wear a condom and she's not
barren and you [ __ ] bust in or yeah
that that could happen that's not
murphy's law dude
let's not blame the irish for this one
too all right we came to
uh to the decision not to go through
with it
over the weeks she went to to scans so
they
can determine dates and when to do the
deed over the time
at that time she grew attached to the
pregnancy by seeing the heartbeat yeah
in the pictures exactly and ultimately
decided to keep it
well good for her um
over the weeks in that meantime i
struggled with the age difference
oh now you struggle with the age do you
have its [ __ ] struggle when you
[ __ ] busted a nutner
the major reason being i have a
five-year-old son to one woman
and an 18 year old daughter to another
this guy is a [ __ ] piece of work
uh they're the same age your older
daughter yes the same age
uh billy big balls what the [ __ ] do i do
well there's nothing you can do you
gotta he goes my daughter doesn't know
well you gotta tell her
i've told my besties and they're they're
all like bro
you're the king this is just reading
like this isn't real i i
they didn't go like bro you just [ __ ]
your life
uh but i feel like a dud and a bad
father
um i'd say you definitely have some sort
of issues you might want to go to
therapy if this is true
and see why you're banging a thousand
women and
[ __ ] you got a five-year-old with
this one an 18 year old that one now
you're gonna have one with this 19 year
old
um yeah i would definitely say you got
some sort of commitment issues or
something i don't know what but it's
gonna cost you if you were in my country
dude you'd be [ __ ] broke
uh if my daughter was seeing a dude my
age it would be the last day
she saw him alive
okay so
all right so so are you acknowledging
that you were a bit of a dirtbag here
uh but god damn what would a bald
emaciated viking like yourself do
uh i would raise that kid and i'd start
wearing a [ __ ] condom is what i would
do
stay blessed stay healthy stay being
awesome everyday listener
to something of your work for years now
yeah buddy
uh listen dude you got to get your dick
under control
your dick is [ __ ] your life up uh you
don't have control over it
and your dick is deciding what you're
going to do rather than your brain
because if you looked at all of that on
paper
if you talk to the younger you now i
know you love your kids and everything
okay didn't you you wanted to find
i don't think that you wanted to have a
bunch of kids with a bunch of different
women
um i mean that makes it really
difficult but i mean it is your life so
what i would do is i would
man up to what you did i would tell my
daughters about it
i'd go to therapy if you feel if you
agree with what i'm saying i would start
wearing a condom
um and uh
you know i try to
get with women my own age or within
reason
you know what i mean i mean okay i'll go
with the fact you thought she was 26 but
when you found out she was 19 not only
do you still go oh
i guess you found on a date you still
bang her
you bust a nutner i mean those were
you know what's the nicest way of saying
really [ __ ] stupid moves
um yeah buddy what are you doing man
i'm getting stressed reading this whole
[ __ ] thing
um yeah that's what i would do
i mean you just gotta you gotta
you gotta raise this kid is what you
gotta do i
i would i don't know where you're now
soon to be three kids live
i would pick an apartment right in the
middle of all of them and i would
dedicate
the next 20 years of my life to making
sure that five-year-old and that
your new kid um
don't have daddy issues so they don't go
to a gym
and bang some 38 year old without a
[ __ ] condom
all right good luck to you brother
sexting sexting all right
this isn't really well this is about
this guy he remember i told you that
story
um about that dude uh
he worked for some corporations sea of
cubicles all right
and then i'm sure he's on some sort of
team right and everybody has to do some
sort of song before they go in there
like those
poor kids morale building exercises yeah
like those people who work at
the cold stone creamery you ever see
them like with like making like
the goddamn uh ice cream going hi ho
hi-ho
it's off to work i just that that like a
part of me
dies when i see that when i just see
people like uh
it's like basically watching someone
work in like an ice cream death camp
when i'm in there
none of them are happy none of them
dreamed of doing that
ice cream death came maybe maybe if
you're like a
fatty you know when you got a job at an
ice cream store kind of like a pedophile
getting a job at like a a cub scout camp
wow you know isn't that where they
always end up
i love working with kids oh god you know
i said that last week follow your dreams
unless you're a pedophile yeah
right so i don't accident using that i
shouldn't say that i have a problem with
uh
fatties working in the ice cream store
let's let's let's get to this [ __ ] so
anyways
so they're going to get everybody in
shape so they hire some sort of personal
trainer and he's training everybody
all right and what he does is he gets
everybody's emails right great move on
this guy's part
[ __ ] great move now he doesn't have
to deal with them face to face and if
there's any [ __ ] hotties he wants to
bang
he can take it to the next level perfect
yeah that's how you do it
it's okay shooting fish in a [ __ ]
barrel or fishing barreled in a in a
shooting gallery
um so
anyways so that all of a sudden this guy
notices that you know he gets one text
going hey brad you know just do a couple
more uh jumping jacks and you should be
fine
for some reason his little hottie wife
has to get like 40 [ __ ] texts from
this guy at like 11
30 at night oh i do remember this yeah
he and his wife work at the same place
obviously yeah that's interesting i work
at the same place right
so he [ __ ] uh he finds out about he
keeps asking his wife
i remember this okay all right well i'm
gonna recap for people who listen last
week all right
so he keeps asking us keeps catching his
wife late at night
texting going and he goes who are you
texting and she would immediately slam
the phone shut because she's got a flip
phone
evidently and would say uh nobody either
would say nobody or
get mad and say nobody right so this
guy's not a [ __ ] he figures out
something's up
sure he's in he's into some sort of
[ __ ] spy gate [ __ ]
where he's at he hacks into her thing
gets her password and sees that
all these text messages back and forth
to trainers so
what does he do he's a goddamn man does
he slap his [ __ ] wife around
no he goes right to the trainer and says
he slaps him around
and says hey sport no because you get
sued you get sued for that now
you get sued for kicking somebody's ass
when you're right yeah um
you go he goes hey sport once you do me
a favor and stop texting my [ __ ] wife
in all hours of the night
so then uh sporto there immediately
starts acting like a [ __ ] around him
starts acting overly nice
like you know what all guilty people do
right he's innocent he would have gotten
mad
sure be like dude what the [ __ ] are you
talking about i always text people
about how to get make their core
stronger at two in the morning
i'm dedicated maybe you should be
inspired by what i'm doing
i specifically i am interested in women
having a strong court because they're so
beaten down in society you know he would
have come back with some [ __ ] like that
but he didn't now he's all like hey man
how are you
please don't beat the [ __ ] out of me and
expose me for being the dirt bag i am so
i lose this giant
money-making client here right so
anyways she denies the whole [ __ ]
thing so he sent a couple of uh
actually a couple of texts that this
girl wrote
uh they were talking about the beatles
and
uh he writes all those damn beatles
songs make my stomach hurt when i listen
to them
because it reminds me of getting ready
to go see you
they give me anxiety this is what the
trainer is writing to this guy's wife
now what what sort of uh
exercise are they talking about there is
that uh what is that is that push-ups
so then she writes back all the lonely
people
where do they all belong oh god right
and then he said i remember you asking
me if i related to that song
if i related that song to you because i
thought you were lonely
it's talking about our [ __ ] marriage
yeah
oh this guy this guy's a dirtbag it's
the
i love him i love it it's the classic he
listens to me
yeah oh this guy he's just saying
everything we talk about
music yeah my feelings oh yes
my husband doesn't do that right and
what it is his dick
is is is downloading all the knowledge
in this guy's brain that he has about
human beings
and he's just given her and the dick is
just is is basically sitting in the
captain kirk chair
he's just [ __ ] anything she wants to
hear so anyways
um then he write another one he said i
know [ __ ] my life i wear
my [ __ ] my life to sleep and i have a
confession to make
i also wear your panties
she goes lol shut up he writes it's
true so i don't know what kind of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this guy's into but the real
question is
not whether or not that that's socially
acceptable the real question is
how did he get this married woman's
panties
he at least finger blaster would you go
with me on that i mean if i mean maybe
he's just saying that to be just like
controversial that's what i thought
but she goes lol shut up he goes it's
true yeah but he just still may be
joking are you talking to the mic
oh he may still be joking around but if
he is wearing
but if he is she gave it to him how else
would he have him
and they were talking about the beatles
and [ __ ] she gave it to him
okay so well that's basically what i'm
saying so [ __ ] he's got a [ __ ]
panties
they're both adults i'm guessing by this
she's like in her 30s
what is he doing fingering her and
taking her out for a malt
he's banging her he [ __ ] banged her
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] would be a
great movie because a great character
for a [ __ ] movie
um so anyways he said that's what he
said his wife she's still dennis denying
this whole conversation ever happened
she's just incomplete obviously denial
she's in denial he said i'm dumping her
uh not for the reminiscing talk but
for lying to me uh
he's not interested in trying to uh
please say that nia and i swear to god
i'm gonna throw my computer
i will throw this [ __ ] computer at
you are you [ __ ] he's not interested
in what
i don't know
working it out don't throw it out no no
no go ahead
i'm just going to leave you in dead
silence go ahead tell me no no no no no
i just
i don't know no he's well within his
right i was just posing a question
that's all
well within his right i don't understand
why she
it doesn't just fess up then all right
that's a whole nother topic that's a
whole nother topic i mean what
i feel like no you know
no i feel like part of the story is
missing or something what the video of
them [ __ ]
is is that what's missing what else is
missing yeah if he's like hey
nia if you start blaming him for not
paying attention and that's why she's
[ __ ] this guy i will
i will [ __ ] throw you out of this
room all right no i'm not dude calm down
that's not what i'm doing i'm just
saying
so he says to her are you cheating on
are you [ __ ] this guy
and she's like no shut up what are you
talking about like and she just flat out
tonight i don't understand how she can
flat out deny
something as hard because she's a piece
of [ __ ] that's why i'm
she's a lying piece of [ __ ] nia yeah but
if you have something and you're like
looking at it like this is what you
wrote
how are you denying it because she just
she's
that's what denial is you're totally in
denial i don't have a drinking problem
is your [ __ ] drinking on nyquil i
think it tastes good i don't have a
problem
right yeah i like sleeping
you know uh yeah
you know what it is i'm just making sure
you keep speaking to the mic this is
what you keep that
i want people to hear what you have to
say oh okay all right all right
but this is good [ __ ] and i'm ruining it
no
you're saying it off my good [ __ ]
lord
you know what kills me is he was still
like it's just
i don't know i'm gonna piss you off
right now you ladies
will definitely because you guys defend
each other like right there
if a guy did that i'm not defending her
well let me can i get out my what i'm
gonna say if a guy did that [ __ ] you'd
be like dump his ass
girl he's a [ __ ] loser you can do
better than that call me
we'll eat a little moon pie i'll build
you up that's what the [ __ ] you would
have done
but because yeah i just feel like some
part of the story is missing like what
is missing
i guess nothing thank you nia
thank you for being on the podcast yeah
is that what you want yeah you just want
me to come on and
agree with you a good [ __ ] 20 minutes
yeah
not agree with me agree with the
decision this guy made this isn't about
me nia
please okay i'm just a messenger here
sure you know
i'm just trying to do i'm just trying to
do what's right because it's very clear
what's happening and you got someone
who's just like i don't know what you're
talking about
all right here's the deal man or woman
um if the person you're with is texting
past i would even for regular people who
aren't in show business
the booty hour starts after 11 i would
say
after 11 yeah okay but that's but that's
what somebody you're already [ __ ]
okay i know you don't understand it
because you don't have to talk yourself
into it guys we have to spin the plates
from the second we meet her
all the way through so you got to be
setting it up
okay you know 7 30 is is too creepy and
stalkerish
um and i would say uh you start going
past 9 30
she's gonna feel like like you're just
she's some sort of [ __ ] if you haven't
[ __ ] her yet right so you gotta eat
that's that there's that window
uh-huh about 8 15 to about 907
you have to do the setup text okay and
the setup text
is not talking about [ __ ] it's go oh
you know i'm i'm watching blah blah on
tv
uh so-and-so is so ridiculous some sort
of [ __ ] just to get it going
you know what i mean right something
that seems very benign yeah like a boxer
you feel them out in the first round or
the beatles yeah you don't load it up
right
you're feeling it up yeah that's what
they're doing right
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] this this
guy
you know something as much as a piece of
[ __ ] is that that guy is
if he writes a book i would read it in a
second why
because you know he's got great i mean
the position he has
that's like when i used to take i used
to take that uh that yoga class when i
was out here
and there was that guy out in santa
monica and he was a phenomenal [ __ ]
teacher
right and this place was jam-packed and
it was by donation only
so then for tax purposes i think he
falls under a church
i know it helped him with taxes and it's
all in cash
so it's all good all right and then the
hottest [ __ ] women
some of the hottest women ever move out
to la to become actresses okay
he's got him in his class getting all
getting them all stretched out
before he bangs him it was one of the
greatest it was it was [ __ ] airtight
yeah and he would go around the class
and somehow me having never touched my
toes since i was in the womb
was somehow always doing every position
correctly yet all these other hotties
always needed to be adjusted
yeah right around the soaz
so i don't get mad at a guy who's got a
good thing but you you know stay away
from the [ __ ] married ladies
yes um all right let's go to advice
for the week um advice lady at the
office
wants it okay hey bill i was wondering
if you
and the lovely nia if she's around could
help me with an issue i've been having
the past couple of months
it has to do with the [ __ ] lady at
work
um so this girl started at my office a
little over two months ago
and i've been training her on basically
everything
so we've been spending a lot of time
together
cue the porno music all right um now
this girl is by no means
a smoke show but she is cute and she's
the type of girl
who gets more attractive when you get to
know her because she's pretty cool
we have a lot in common like musical
tastes and we both like the same beer
among other things oh so you've
obviously gone drinking
or at the very least you've discussed
you know going out and having a few
you know what's so funny about that sir
you didn't even think of that question
you addicted
your dick is always closing your dick is
always
in a two-minute offense you know but you
got to be careful because
just like brett favre it will throw back
over the middle
for a pick six and i think that that's
what you're about ready to do if you
start banging some broad at work
um unless you have the skills
let me finish reading this thing here
all right our job requires a lot of time
on the road oh god this is just totally
set up
our job requires a lot of time in the
road so we have a lot of time to talk to
each other while in the car
uh you're in the car she smells good
she's crossing her legs how many times
you got a [ __ ] heart on this you've
been driving with her
trying to keep up some stupid
conversation as your dick's going do it
do it
um anyways a lot of what we've been
talking about
is hook up hookups and sex
and what we both like and don't like
dude this is a layup you're in there
and as i could have predicted a bit of
sexual tension began to arise
what do you mean you could have
predicted dude
don't [ __ ] play this game with me
all right you know what you're doing
a little bit of sexual tension that you
[ __ ] created
you're steering the conversation towards
this exactly like you should be doing
this is right down the checklist
by the time i get done reading this
you'll probably [ __ ] blow a loading
her
you're doing everything you can to [ __ ]
this girl anyways what didn't help the
situation
was one day when we admit to each other
that we would bang each other
if she didn't have a boyfriend oh jesus
dude listen before we go any further
i totally respect what you're doing here
all right what i don't respect
is the way you're you're telling it to
me
as if this [ __ ] is just happening and
you're not manipulating the situation
okay
you totally manipulate the situation
this is like
t-ball this is like [ __ ] t-ball at this
point it's just sitting right there
waiting for you to knock it out of the
park
and it was all because of the excellent
[ __ ] work that you've done all right
i'm going to continue to read this
all right but i want to tell you and
everybody else don't [ __ ] talk to me
like i'm an idiot
yeah i guess just you know when i had
the sexual tension
because we're sitting there talking
about banging how did you get on that
subject
what dumb subject was she talking about
as you sat there and sort of [ __ ]
forced the conversation you know not
forced because then she would have known
you just sort of gradually uh
how did you do it how'd you compliment
her shoes or something
you know that's always a good thing you
know it's a great [ __ ] way
if you're trying to figure out how to
turn the topic to sex
and you're you know you're not at a bar
or anything is you actually compliment
another woman
that walks by wow there's a beautiful
woman i could really
you know and women just find that
fascinating why what do you like about
it blah blah blah
blah and you start with that as the jump
off point and then you're in
you know then you're in you're in
okay just don't reach out and grab a
titty in a moment of [ __ ] reflex
though
because then you'll have a problem all
right here we go the sexual tension only
got worse as we talked
as we talked about it more saying what
we would do if we ever hooked up with
each other
yeah first of all this girl does not
love her boyfriend
and uh yeah yeah this is this is over
this is like a [ __ ] red shoe diary at
this point uh meanwhile when we are in
the office
she calls me from her desk from her desk
to mine and sends me email
trying to chit chat and [ __ ] and
basically flirts hardcore
uh see right there dude right there
right there
you just had a meltdown in the nuclear
plant it's starting to spill over
you got to get this girl under wraps
this is bad
uh to the point where people have asked
if there's anything going on between
us uh you're sloppy you're young and
you're sloppy
uh when we're out of work she texts me
constantly
which gets a little annoying but i'd be
a liar if i didn't like it because i
mean who doesn't like flirting
with an attractive lady you told me
before that she wasn't really that
attractive
but after a while she starts getting
more attractive what after she says she
wants to suck your dick
oh [ __ ] you know what this is this chick
is like a virus and she's already
contaminated your entire workspace this
this might be beyond my help
i don't even know where you're going
with this anyways the situation came to
a head one saturday night
when she texts me saying she wants to be
drunk honest
with me i literally said oh jesus to
myself
why you created this situation
and he goes and i asked what she meant
she went on to say she wanted to make
out with me because she's never felt
this way about someone
and even though she loves her boyfriend
who she's about to move in with
and plans on marrying she doesn't think
that making out with me
is a big deal i kind of brushed it off
as a drunk text and when she texted me
the next day i asked her if she had
changed
my and she said no and she still wanted
to
so i asked so i asked you this sir
what the [ __ ] do i do i know it sucks to
be cheated on because i've been cheated
on
and i don't want to do that to this dude
because i've met her boyfriend once and
he's a good guy
at the same time he's not my friend
here's where his dick comes in to argue
the other side of it
at the same time he's not my friend and
therefore i feel i need
i need to be loyal i don't need to be
loyal to him
by not hooking up with his girlfriend i
know be a sleazeball move on my part but
she's old enough to make her own
decisions
and she has told me it wouldn't have it
wouldn't affect a relationship with him
oh jesus dude whether or not she's actu
that's actually
true i won't know unless i go through
with this and wait for the fallout
exactly
once again she she told me she wants to
do that
she wants to all she wants to do is make
out and not
bang but i know myself and as a 23 year
old guy
making out doesn't quite do it for me
anymore so i know i'll try to go further
let me know what you think thanks in
advance love the podcast
all right all right all right
the question you got to ask you need to
ask two questions
how much do you like your job and two
can her boyfriend beat the [ __ ] out of
you does he have any felony convictions
or anything like that because this whole
thing is going to blow up in your face
um this is a confused woman
she doesn't know what she wants to do
she doesn't know how to be in a
relationship
she's [ __ ] she's actually using you
um and you guys are going to [ __ ]
you might not [ __ ] the first time but
you're gonna [ __ ] and then you're gonna
[ __ ] on a regular basis
unless you decide you don't want to and
it's going to get
weird this is one of these girls no
matter what it's going to get [ __ ]
weird
so all right
i don't know what to tell you here
because i i don't know all the details
but
the smart move here is to not [ __ ] this
woman
okay people already know there's sexual
tension
so if you know she has a boyfriend they
know she has a boyfriend
and you're just gonna look like a piece
of [ __ ] and the whole thing's going to
blow up and it's going to be gossip and
you have any sort of
like desire to move up in that country
your country that company you're really
going to [ __ ]
screw that aspect of it up um there's
plenty of [ __ ] women you're 23 years
old you're in the prime of your [ __ ]
life go out and [ __ ] somebody else
all right and that whole thing there you
know she's got a boyfriend and you know
blah blah blah blah i agree with you
that's not your [ __ ] fault
okay but the thing about it is what
makes it weird is you're going to see
this girl again the next day
and the next day and the next day you
know what's going to happen is you know
you're in your head you'll be like yeah
we just [ __ ] because she said we're
just [ __ ]
and she said it isn't a big deal because
she said it isn't a big deal
and you know what she's gradually going
to suck you into having a [ __ ]
relationship with her and you're going
to
have to break up with somebody that
you're not even going out with at
[ __ ] work
and then she's gonna make your life a
living hell this [ __ ] girl not only
can she not keep her goddamn legs close
you know she can't keep her [ __ ]
mouth shut she's gonna talk to somebody
else and the whole thing's gonna [ __ ]
blow up
all right so
my advice to you is don't [ __ ] this girl
have a mature conversation with her and
say look
it'd be one thing if you were single
but you're not you have a boyfriend i
feel bad i met the guy
you want to move in with them you want
to get married this is the way you do
you just
i just i really find you attractive i
would really love to hook up with you
but
i just i can't i wasn't raised that way
you just
back out of it that way and just get the
[ __ ] out of it man i'm telling you
unless you haven't been laid in a while
and you don't give a [ __ ] about your job
then just
[ __ ] bang her right on your goddamn
desk in front of the security cameras
you know put your website write it on
your back
[Laughter]
and you know what [ __ ] come right in
her face
give this dirty [ __ ] what she [ __ ]
deserves
you know but other than that
i'm telling you the downfall of men
it's our dicks our dicks get us in more
[ __ ] goddamn trouble
than anything else and if you can
somehow make a rational decision
despite the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] your dick
is saying
your dick is like that diva wide
receiver on the football team
screaming for the ball every other play
you know
and you know god damn well it's double
coverage
okay all you need to do is just [ __ ]
wind down the last two minutes of the
game and as you
you [ __ ] douche screaming at you what
are you gonna do
you know that's a tough one
that's really a tough one but but you
know if you're gonna break up with it
just
act like you're an honorable human being
and just say i can't do it because you
have a boyfriend just say it like you
believe it
and then get out of it and i and you
watch you watch what happens
okay there's still going to be fallout
to that it's just
it just feels like weird like you're not
like talking to me anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you psycho
you already have a situation on your
hands please by by the way i'm actually
invested in this emotionally now
i want to know what happens please let
me know if you [ __ ]
if you don't [ __ ] her what happens what
doesn't happen and all that all right
um jesus christ
jesus that's a [ __ ] situation all
right can't get laid
uh bill i'm a huge fan i listen to all
your podcasts and stand up
now that i'm done sucking your dick i
love how you guys just can't give me a
[ __ ] compliment
and then you feel all uncomfortable
because you actually enjoy the comp
the the [ __ ] podcast just be a man
and give me a goddamn compliment
you know does so good you're
uncomfortable i'm not uncomfortable i
enjoy the praise
he says i need some advice i'm starting
my sophomore year
of college and i've never been more
depressed my high school girlfriend
broke up with me shortly after
graduation and i haven't gotten laid
since
uh it's not like i stay in my room all
day i have friends and i go to parties
at least once a week and even though i
never enjoy
even though i never enjoy myself i just
can't get a girl to be interested in me
i also have no idea what i want to do
after college and so i have no
motivation to apply myself
the only reason i haven't dropped out is
because my parents who are paying
thousands and thousands of dollars i
don't drop out so they won't be
disappointed
i work out every day and i try to stay
busy but most of the time i just feel
terrible
i'm hoping you have some advice for me
if not go [ __ ] yourself and if you do
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right um
you obviously have a sense of humor um
what would my advice be uh you know what
i think you're trying too hard
all right there's no reason to to go to
a party not have a good time
just go there and enjoy yourself don't
worry about talking to women don't worry
about trying to get laid
just have a good time just enjoy
yourself just go out in life and just
[ __ ]
enjoy yourself okay people are
attractive
to positive energy and somebody having a
good time it makes them want to be
around you
and next thing you know somebody's
blowing you
i don't understand why the universe
works that way but it does i know i am
overly simplifying this
but um you know it's good that you know
that you're depressed
i was depressed for about 20 years and
didn't realize it because i was so used
to feeling that way i thought it was
just the
normal you know just the normal
state of things um i gotta tell you this
dude
you are gonna get a girlfriend and
you're gonna find love and you're gonna
get married
okay but i gotta tell you there's a
[ __ ] misery that comes to that life
all right there's a great thing but
there's also a misery and she feels it
[ __ ] too
and that's a part of you you're the
individual you dies
so right now dude you are the 40 year
old
you is gonna look back at the [ __ ] if
the 40 year old you
could get in a time machine and sit down
with you right now
and give you a [ __ ] pregame speech
before you went to that party
i mean that would be like scared
straight he'd be right in your face
you know you have any idea
what it's like to get up at five in the
morning and change your shitty diaper
you get to sleep 10 hours a [ __ ] day
you can't put a smile on your face when
you go to a [ __ ] party
single you could [ __ ] anything that
walks
you go down to that 7-eleven look at me
you go down to that 7-eleven you get
yourself a box of [ __ ] condoms
you stick them and you stick one in your
pocket
prepare for success
you are in your goddamn shirt you get
down there you have a good [ __ ] time
all right you're only gonna be this age
once
he's saying something like that all
right
i'm telling you you're only going to be
this age once you're in college dude
you are at like you're it's like you won
the nba draft
lottery women there are in the prime of
their [ __ ] life
most of them are [ __ ] single it's
gonna happen for you
but if you're walking around and you're
depressed and you're carrying that with
you if you're moping around like that
that makes people [ __ ] you know
not want to be around you so i would say
drinking is probably not a good thing
because that is a depressant
so scratch that i can't remember if i
[ __ ] told you to to have a couple of
beers i wouldn't do that i would just
[ __ ] enjoy yourself
i almost you know what i would do i
would go do some [ __ ] for you
[ __ ] trying to get a girlfriend [ __ ]
trying to get laid [ __ ] all of that just
go out and
what do you want to do if you don't know
what you want to do go out and go try a
bunch of different things and have a
good time dude you're single
okay you don't have to [ __ ] you don't
have to [ __ ] deal with
trying to figure out what's gonna make
them happy
okay because as far as i can [ __ ]
tell
there isn't anything that's gonna make
him happy for
longer than maybe a day
the amount of [ __ ] that you can do for
him and as you can tell
she's a couple of rooms away the amount
of [ __ ] that you can [ __ ] do for him
and all it does is buy you a couple of
days of happiness it's just [ __ ]
baffling and i gotta be honest with you
a lot of women look at guys and they
think that we're [ __ ] stupid
and i think part of it is because they
have um the way their brain works
that multitasking whatever is that [ __ ]
talk that they always say you know that
women can multitask and guys can't
well i would say generally speaking this
is very general
i think men have an advantage when it
comes to just
being happy you know what i mean
like you wouldn't know it for my podcast
and the way i talk and [ __ ] but i'm
happy i'm happy as hell and i've been
happy for a long [ __ ] time
you know all i need dude that's all i
[ __ ] need the nfl package
i got a six of [ __ ] millers
in my in my goddamn refrigerator
you know i got a new pair of sneakers
it's just some
stupid [ __ ] like that i order a
[ __ ] pizza
that's all i need i'm happy the whole
[ __ ] day
you know i go on a hike with my dog in
the morning that's it i'm good
simple simple stupid [ __ ]
keeps me as a guy entertained i don't
have their high level brain that they're
always talking about their ability i can
do a thousand [ __ ] things yeah
look at you you're miserable you're
[ __ ] miserable
so i'm telling you dude you're actually
you don't realize it but where you are
right now dude is
you are in an absolute utopia do you
know how many [ __ ]
guys right now would kill to be in your
position
they'd even take two years of not
getting laid who gives a [ __ ]
rub one out get on with your goddamn day
you know get on with your [ __ ] day of
being single
not having to answer to anybody and
having the option
of hitting on any beautiful woman that
catches your eye
take a trip any time you [ __ ] want go
wherever you want to go do whatever the
[ __ ] dude you're never going to get
and your parents are paying for your
[ __ ] education dude
you're never going to be freer
all right so start looking at your life
that way
and i'm telling you you're gonna have a
different [ __ ] vibe and i
i'm i you know and i'll tell you right
now you start doing that
good things are gonna happen in the
national football league
no i'm serious dude something good is
gonna happen but there will be a time in
your [ __ ] life i'm telling you
where you will be married you'll have
kids and you'll do that whole [ __ ]
thing and that will be
its own sort of utopia but it's
it's i don't dude this is a very it's a
beautiful selfish time in your life
that you should embrace and you should
not uh
you should not spend it feeling bad
about yourself all right
so there you go good luck to you all
right
hypocrisy of the female gender oh
geez come on guys
come on ladies you know what women
trash the guys let's have this [ __ ]
be balanced here fair and balanced
all right what do we got here
hypocrisy of the female gender my
[ __ ]
my batteries are gonna run out here i
gotta get through this one quickly hey
bill
aka bill gizet shot
during the summer that really has
nothing to do with my name
that's just sort of my first name and
then a [ __ ] shot
but you know you tried he goes i'm in a
bit of a pickle
please he got jills he's got a phallic
veg is that a vegetable
it's a pickle a vegetable or a fruit
well let's see bill you're planting
cucumbers
it's not on a tree it's in the ground
it's a [ __ ] vegetable look at me mr
[ __ ] green jeans here
anyways could be serious could be just
something that'll blow over but i'd like
your opinion anyway
um here we go a few days ago
while i was getting a coffee i saw my
girlf
girlfriend's best friend kissing a dude
that doesn't
look like her boyfriend but like the
rational human being that i
am i thought i asked my girl before i
jumped to any conclusion
so i asked her if her boyfriend's still
her boyfriend she said yes and asked why
so i told her
what i saw and her reaction is something
i didn't expect
she went silent so i asked her if she
already
knew and said and she said yes and
begged me not to tell the guy
so i said that i'd like to hear your
hear this
wait so i said that i'd like to hear the
story first
oh my story first
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm just
going to read the way i wrote it so i
said that i said that i'd like to hear
the story first so i can assess
how i want to go about the situation i'm
sorry and she refused
so i said i guess it would be the same
way if you were cheating on me huh
you would act the same way and you two
would conspire over it
and she denied that started crying and
said she would never cheat on me
i told her it was [ __ ] [ __ ] that
she's implying that this [ __ ] of a best
friend
has even the slightest legit reason to
be a piece of [ __ ]
and i eventually left to go get some air
though it was difficult since she caused
a scene and started screaming down the
hall for me
i love when they do that right because
me the second woman starts screaming
in public the guy's like at the very
least
a borderline rapist um
all right well so far okay
you know i'm gonna just read the rest
because at that point she was breaking
down crying and asked me to come back
but i was [ __ ] done
the funny thing is about this the funny
thing about this is
i barely even know the guy i met him
like twice he seems like a cool
down-to-earth guy and all
but i don't really owe him anything yet
what's happening just triggers something
in my mind and i feel like i should tell
him
multiple people know his girlfriend is
cheating on him and he has no [ __ ]
clue i really lost a lot of respect for
my girlfriend but she's always
talks about loyalty and how important it
is to her and how she hates cheaters
because she knows how it feels to be on
the other end
what a [ __ ] hypocrite when confronted
with the situation head on
she just excuses it and mitigates it
with secret
what she mitigates it with secret court
nsa legal reasoning
so i have to believe no did it cut out
was it cutting out hello hello hello
something sounds weird i think it's
still taping right
oh jesus all right trying to read even
faster here
um the [ __ ] is going on with the sound
now
hang on hang on hang on there we go i'm
back
and i'm back um
this is the worst read ever i'm sorry
because this is very interesting
uh i can't even look her look at her or
talk to her right now just thinking
about the way she reacted
to to all of this still pisses me off so
what should i do here do i tell him
i don't know maybe i should just say
[ __ ] him he can't save the world right
and what about my girlfriend
she's quick to say cheating's wrong
until her and her group
are on are the ones doing the cheating
am i just slowly riding along this [ __ ]
to eventually
to eventual heartbreak help me out bill
you sexy beast you
um all right well there's a lot of
variables here uh
it's really the cheating girlfriend has
put your girlfriend in a position
um where she's dragged her into her [ __ ]
you know where now she has to choose
between her friendship to her
and her feelings about cheating and um
i imagine it's her friend she loves her
and she doesn't want to
blow up her life um
i don't know i think i think what really
needs to happen here
is you don't need to get involved
i think your girlfriend
needs to go to her girlfriend
and tell her the situation that her
cheating has put herself in
and that she needs to [ __ ] end it
with this other guy and grow up and
start acting like a [ __ ] adult
because her piece of [ __ ] behavior is
affecting
your girlfriend's relationship and
where you never had trust issues you now
do you know
i'm not saying that your your your
thoughts that your current girlfriend
will now cheat on you
are unfounded but there's two sides to
loyalty too where you know you'd help
your friend move a body
you know there's people like that like
you know
this cheater might be stringing your
girlfriend along going i know
i'm just confused right now i'm sorry i
just need
i feel like i need something different
but i still love mike
and i'm trying to i'm just doing a
little dick shopping i'm sorry
i had to see it it's like the [ __ ]
farmer's market whatever the [ __ ] she's
saying
right um
[ __ ] her friend i feel bad for the other
dude what are you gonna do i would just
sit down with your
your girlfriend and just be like look
this is what this is what has to go down
all right
you know what whatever the [ __ ] i just
said you need to go talk to your
girlfriend and tell her that she needs
to [ __ ] clear up her situation
uh because it's affecting my
relationship okay grow up break up with
this other [ __ ] guy
you know and uh get on with your life
that that's what i would suggest and
um and but i don't think you're wrong to
now be looking at your girlfriend like
what the [ __ ]
and uh i never believe when a woman
cries when you call him out on [ __ ] i
never do because i don't believe
that i don't believe the crying as a
rule
because they can cry on cue like meryl
streep
you know um
they just they just have access to that
emotion and uh
it automatically makes them the victim
it makes you feel like you're a bully
i think you're 100 right to feel the way
you did uh you might have gone at her a
little too strong
uh i've given you an option uh i hope it
works out for you
um in the meantime do you think you're
gonna marry this girl
because if you don't you're just wasting
time and this is a great [ __ ]
uh jump off point to get the [ __ ] out of
it you know
nfl football starts next month that
money you're spending on her going to
the movies would look very nice
with the nfl package you got a lot of
options here sir
good luck to you all right back to
school hello mr burr
i'm about to start start my sophomore
year of high school soon
and i want to know if you can give me
some advice
yeah don't do what i did i said my
grades were pretty good last year so
that really isn't a problem dude that's
[ __ ] huge
keep your grades up keep your options
wide open
unlike mine that [ __ ] closed
immediately uh for this upcoming year
uh also also the whatever the grades
aren't a problem for this upcoming year
but the girls of my school are
i have no problem making friends in both
genders but i can't really seal the deal
with the ladies
i know i am young and probably shouldn't
not be worrying about sex
yet but as hor but as a horny teenager
oh jesus christ
please tell me this is a guy he said i
feel the need
all he said with women but you know you
never know i said i feel the need
to at least try and get laid i can't
seem to be taken seriously by girls in
my school they seem to think i'm just a
comedian
and not a possible sexual partner
any advice on how to get with these
girls any advice is appreciated and i
know you get a lot of advice questions
so thank you very much for reading this
ah god damn it he went respectful
i love your stanford podcast you film
blah blah heat breaking bad thank you i
appreciate all that
um i didn't get laid in high school so i
you're asking you're barking up the
wrong [ __ ] tree i was i was you
i was you i was making my friends laugh
but i didn't have i didn't have women
friends either
so you're further along than i am so i
actually ask you
how did you do that i wasn't even like
oh dude it was a [ __ ] barren
wasteland
my my childhood was overloaded
testosterone so overloaded that like i
don't even like
you know i am just getting like my views
and understanding on women at 46
like i should have been plowing through
this at like 19
um i just
as far as understanding how where
they're coming from
so uh what can what advice can i give
you
um um um stop being friends with with
women uh see bad advice like i wouldn't
do that
there's that there's that whole [ __ ]
bit chris rock did where if you stay
friends with him too long
they view you that way and then
looking at you as a sexual partner
becomes gross
um so what is this a deal
i'm not gonna go negative stay friends
with the women you're friends with
all right but don't become friends with
any other ones
hit on all the other ones all right if
you're if you're in a really small
[ __ ] pond
go to a [ __ ] party the next town over
and be the mysterious guy from the other
town although if there's football
players there they might
just beat the [ __ ] out of you at least
that's what would happen when i was a
kid so watch out for that [ __ ]
um i don't know i would say the upside
is that college is only two years away
college is only two years away and this
is the deal you're gonna be thinking
back
all the [ __ ] women that you could
have [ __ ] been having fun with
um so you just you got to put it out
there man i think that that's what
you're doing i think you're being like
uh you you don't know how to [ __ ] get
into that traffic pattern
you know you're just sort of circling
the [ __ ] you're in a holding pattern
here man you got you got to try to come
in for a landing
and uh i would say any girl that you are
friends with
it's [ __ ] over don't even try to hook
up with them
don't wear them out all right i would
actually you know what i would do
a couple of them i would talk to them
i would talk to them you know what if
you're friends with them they'll try and
hook you up with some other girl
who they'll see is like well you know
she wants to meet a boy
that's there you go that might be the
way to get in there
hey nia can you help this kid get laid
this is beyond this is beyond my realm
it's it's a it's a [ __ ] it's a it's a
kid in high school
some kid in high school he he has no
problem making friends he's doing well
in school
he has a lot of female friends but he
can't seem to get past that so he's
asking me how does he get laid as a
sophomore in high school i was like i
didn't get
sophomore in high school whatever hook
up you know get him in the game he wants
some at bats
all right so young and cute
he doesn't need to he doesn't want to be
cute this guy wants to be a badass
he's got marlboro man here you got to
build this dude up so so he
he's friends with a lot of women so me
like a [ __ ] you know what i said first
thing you got to do
don't be friends with any more women and
i immediately heard your voice in my
head going you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i was like all right scratch that
so i came up with don't try to hook up
with any of the girls you're friends
with because
they've already stopped looking at you
like you're a sexual being it's going to
seem gross
in the friend zone yeah the chris chris
rock classic chris rock
the friend zone so i said
a couple of them that you feel like you
can trust just kind of put it out there
like hey you know i
have a girl girls just you you you
play uh you back away like hey you know
girls they don't want to hook up with me
they
oh gee they just look at me like i'm
just funny
and then they'll be like what are you
talking about you have a lot to offer
and then i think that they'll maybe hook
him up
with some other girl that they know that
is probably maybe saying the same [ __ ]
yeah but he probably knows all those
girls though i feel like he's
to move outside his circle of uh the
girls that he's friends with
i mean if he wants to sort of be like do
you guys think i'm i don't know
do some sort of like i don't know what
am i cool am i like do you think girls
want to like date me because i just feel
like you know you can't say am i cool
once you say am i cool you're not cool
anymore
well i suggested i suggested that he go
to another town but i'm worried he's
going to run into the town
yeah be the mysterious guy where you
from huh the next town over
you should see our 7-eleven baby if
there's a girl that he likes he should
just go up and just start talking to her
but just make it clear
not by being like i want to date you or
i want to [ __ ] you because i'm looking
to get
not like that but just like oh that's
bad yeah
just start like you know just being
funny and and all that kind of stuff and
just being cool with her
but definitely like you got to put up
the flirtatious vibe
that's what it is it's all about
properly flirting
you know what i mean and not like
lingering too long with it
and not like oh can i you know just
showing up at her locker
you know in between classes already
there like hey so
going to algebra huh like not like that
lingering's bad i learned that the hard
way
were you a lingerer and i was quiet so i
look like a psycho
creepy yeah definitely i could see that
i could definitely see that being your
uh
your thing oh when i was younger my
thing like i'm a [ __ ] creep i didn't
know what to do i was all i was old
billy freckles i
wasn't i was a man without a country you
just gotta just flirt with them just be
cute with them give them a compliment
don't go too overboard with it you know
even if it's just something like you
know
all right i'm gonna give you two
compliments sally you know like nice
stress
keep moving and keeping hey sally nice
dress he's gotta give him something
better than that
i'm not really good at this okay because
i feel like it's like a natural thing
that you have
it's all about you know what it is i
think i think once you're secure
with yourself and you're not feeling
those
feelings of inadequacy that's when that
kind of natural
swag can happen you can't manufacture it
so that's why me trying to give him like
lines to throw out sounds ridiculous
because
they're completely manufactured yeah and
also you're a woman so you don't have to
like
hit on people you just show up and look
cute that's why
yeah we've been through this before i'm
not getting into it again that's why at
your
cute age your opening line is hey sally
nice dress
i know that really wasn't terrible but
just give out a compliment
and keep it moving that's all i'm saying
can you come up with a middle ground
between uh
hey sally nice dress and hey uh sally
nice [ __ ] wreck
what what'd i say i don't think that i
can
just make it something like you know
just offhanded
you know oh that's cool what's that or
did i just ask about something about her
you know what's that book you're reading
i'm trying to put in the context of like
a school type of situation so it's not
completely out of left field you know
what you're good at
starting the car getting in right hey
what's that book you're reading and then
she's got to be like um
uh [ __ ] harry potter and then you're
like
saw that movie that's pretty pretty cool
oh god i'm the worst and then your face
turns all red
well the thing about it is too is we're
talking about teenagers here so i don't
know that this is this is [ __ ] creepy
yeah we're a long ways away from being
like
in high school so i can't even like go
back there mentally
to figure out how a boy that age would
talk to a girl i have no idea because i
can't i can't remember anything
previous to insult her a little bit like
that's that's
how i always hit on negging is that what
it's called yeah
tearing them down no not tearing them
down but just
giving them [ __ ] in a funny way yeah
well that's all yeah that can be cute
for sure
tea is like a playful teasing yeah but
it's like you got to know the person
well enough to do that
you know what i mean it's like if it's
some girl that he hasn't talked to
in like three years and all of a sudden
he's like yeah [ __ ]
like she's gonna be like what who's that
yeah no
that's the worst i've learned all these
lessons what was that
did i ever tell you that i feel like
it's less about here's my here's my
final thought on it i think it's less
about oh shut up
i think it's less about how do i get the
girls to like me
yeah i did why'd you tell me to shut up
your face was was saying
things no because no you just i didn't
like what your face was saying to me so
i told her to shut up
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you what my i
was imitating a woman's face when i said
something to her one time that was the
face she made at me
what do you mean what did you say uh you
know
i was in between relationships you
remember just spit it out
no because it's embarrassing i was in
between relationships and all these
comics were just like dude just you know
just [ __ ] say it and blah blah blah
blah and just
stay single and just bang a bunch of
broads and blah blah blah so i tried to
be that guy
so and it was sort of working for me and
then i just
one night it just completely backfired i
was at danger field and this woman came
up to me and told me how much she liked
my you know blah blah blah started the
small talk and everything and then i
tried to be
you know leather jacket guy said hey you
want to just cut through the [ __ ] i
mean i live right up the street if you
want to come
yeah and she goes she just went like
what huh
no no i and she slowly backed away and i
was like
i [ __ ] it took me silly bibi
you blew it there was nothing to blow it
was just [ __ ] it wasn't even there
there was no situation
i completely i misread the whole thing i
feel like this kid
has got to just get his his confidence
and his own personal swag going that's
all it is it's like i feel like
it's not about the other people so much
is about how you feel about yourself
you know and i but i feel like that's
also like a concept that's kind of hard
for
people that you know what dude you're
going to figure it out just keep [ __ ]
trying
say hi just say hi hey how's it going
and keep moving that's what i feel like
you know how you're talking about the
mystery that's way better than
hi sally nice dress i know
that was the [ __ ] worst advice ever
you know judging by your skills and some
of the [ __ ] that i said
back in the day i don't know how we ever
[ __ ] met how do we make it
i mean cause i think we're both you know
it's just
nerds all right beat it i gotta read the
advertising and wrap this up